with the fall of the infamous rogue
agent Aaron Keener a new line of Rogue
agents were put into action to fulfill
what he calls his legacy
with the first Manhunt now concluded
what exactly were they trying to achieve
Molly Henderson co-sign Jupiter was
recruited by the division after proving
herself in the private sector as a
security consultant
leaning on a four-year military
background Jupiter excelled in combat
and physical training exercises
however she was noted as a potential
risk due to her past involvement in
militant activism
she had been part of a group that was
later involved in the kidnapping and
assault of a prominent business
executive
nevertheless nothing could ever be tied
to her as she claimed to have left the
group by the time of the incident
in all psychological evaluations
supported this claim
Jupiter was activated as part of the
division's first wave and it was at this
time that she first met Aaron Kina
her status was changed to Rogue after an
incident in the New York quarantine Zone
where two jtf officers were killed
Jupiter has since been linked to the
murders of at least 15 jtf officers
sometime after this Keener returned to
New York he approached Jupiter and had
her established a team for a future
attack that will be carried out in
Washington DC
we need to go now is our extraction set
I got a boat waiting for you and your
team in Jamaica Bay are you sure you
can't take the lead on this Mission your
team is perfect
work well together and I know I can
trust you to handle things in Washington
really wish you were coming with us
can't leave New York now there's too
much at stake besides my team doesn't
really play well with other
S Fair still who could use more bodies
just in case things go sideways don't
worry I won't let you go without back
one of the first agents that Jupiter got
in contact with was Ryan Chang
tell her out
this is a secure Channel
secure enough
what's your name you want to call sign
for this op
seems smart
France animals zodiac
went to the Planetarium last week
always been partial to Mercury five
Mercury
means Jupiter nice to meet you
is it true you're working with the
cleaners I've got access but Connelly
Uranus is their real leader
Mars brought us together they're
efficient if I had a team like that here
we could have eradicated the outcasts in
a couple of weeks that's the goal
victory was recruited by the division
from the military after earning a silver
star in Afghanistan
he left the military and became a
marketing manager for a technical
Equipment Company
Mercury was activated as part of the
division's second wave but was marked as
Rogue after reportedly torturing and
executing prisoners
he has been described as intelligent and
calculated with the tendency for violent
outbursts
peer reviews regularly described him as
being a bit difficult to work with
earlier on Mercury can be heard arguing
with Kelso regarding the loading of
supplies into a cargo plane
we need to finish getting those supplies
ready for transport this is a mistake
the shipment goes out tonight
we need this gear we have enough
supplies we're just moving the Surplus
if the hyenas or the true Suns find out
about this stockpile if the true Sons
come for us we will need these weapons
to defend ourselves you're a good Agent
Ryan but I need you to help me out and
just
finish the job we don't have time to
argue about this the plane's already on
its way
Mercury felt these supplies will be
better used to help in the fight against
the true sons and the hyenas
the cargo plane in question would later
crash onto Roosevelt Island
not long after this incident Mercury was
marked as Road
Chadwick Brandon Call Sign Neptune was a
flight engineer at the time of
Recruitment and was activated as part of
the division's first wave
his job was to contain the civil unrest
in the early days and to secure the
Midtown quarantine Zone
not long after activation he ran into
another agent called Mike
the two men started working together as
a team forming a tight Bond
during his time with the shd Neptune set
up a lot of the critical infrastructure
at the base of operations including a
set of backup generators that could
guarantee stable power and
Communications
however when the retreat was called in
the quarantine Zone Neptune and Mike
were left surrounded by rioters and no
jtf to support them
while under heavy fire Michael's gunned
down while Neptune only just managed to
escape
dismayed by the loss of his partner and
close friend Neptune held a grudge
towards the jtf
he went on to sabotage the generators
that he helped build in the base of
operations in turn killing eight jtf
staff members and injuring 23 more
after that Neptune disappeared
agent Chadwick Brandon
a Manhattan final Midtown Sid rap
jtf left us behind we lost I don't know
how many ages because of it people who
relied on the jtf support but never got
it
you were supposed to tackle this
together but when the [__] hit the fan
it was clear we were on our own
Mike died because of them we ran into
each other when we first got activated
it worked well together
I wasn't there for him no one was and
now I'll never see him again
we're not going to forget this
Jupiter managed to track Neptune down
and reached out to him
let them come
you think you can handle it
the full Squad storms in
I'll take some of them with me
you die they win
I don't give a [__] anymore
this world can get [__] for all I care
I know you're hurting
I'll leave you with your grief
if you're still alive and want to do
something you know where to find me
we can [__] the world together
initially Neptune refused but after I'd
been given a little more time to mourn
and think over it he got back in contact
with Jupiter
Lucy Anders codenamed Venus was the
first wave division agent
her status changed to Rogue after she
abandoned the mission disappearing for
six weeks
investigations revealed that she had
established her own safe house and was
directly undermining the jtf's work by
claiming critical drops and suppliers
destined for a jtf operations base
later on three division agents were
dispatched to retrieve the stolen
supplies
they managed to locate Venus but two of
the agents were killed and the third was
seriously injured this agent was able to
survive and record an eyewitness account
of the incident
Mary Masters AKA Saturn was an attorney
before she was recruited by the division
she was part of the first wave that was
released after the dollar flew first
struck
however like many before her she turned
Rogue not long after
reports state that she shot down an
extraction helicopter in dark Zone West
in Washington DC killing two jtf pilots
and a division agent
her psychological evaluations indicate
signs of trust issues and a lack of
confidence in others
Mercury
moving out tonight should be in your
solar system in a couple of days what
code
we're coming to your neck of the woods
should be there in a couple of days no
why don't you just say that
we all set
yeah Black Tusk invaded the island but
local agents cleared them doesn't appear
a cargo has been discovered we should
still be good to go right you send me
the coordinates
Morris's Network up and running yet
local test runs but not system-wide
you should still be able to send direct
messages great
you need anything special
if your Intel is correct we should have
everything we need from the crash
Uranus is working on some new prototypes
specs are saved on the network hopefully
we'll be able to test some of them once
we get to Roosevelt
looking forward to it
Jupiter's team were preparing for the
mission
supplies have been stockpiled and were
being loaded into the safe house
one of these included a red package from
arentina
what do you want me to do with it
get rid of it I don't want anything to
do with that you sure you saw what it
could do at City Hall this is the
leverage kingdom was talking about
this isn't some kind of Silver Bullet
Saturn it's a [__] bio weapon we're
doing this to eradicate a virus not
spread something even more dangerous
of course
you're right
I'll destroy it
just be careful
I don't want to find out you dropped it
and killed the whole team
don't worry I've got this under control
yeah that's what they all say until they
don't
this package contained kina's new
supervirus that had been developed by
traninka but Jupiter wanted nothing to
do with this
regardless of what Kino had in mind
Jupiter's mission was still the same to
remove the virus
to do what the jtf and the government
were incapable of doing themselves she
wasn't going to replace the dollar flu
with an even more deadly virus
before Jupiter's team could roll out she
needed to ensure that their
Communications and Logistics would be
robust
she needed someone to stay behind and
hold the fort
when we leave
I need you to stay back on this one
you're kidding
look Saturn you know I trust you yeah
you're the best agent I've got
Venus can be a little
unpredictable and Neptune's barely
keeping it together can you blame them
no
but that right there is why I need you
here
you care about people I need you to make
sure the operation is secure
fine what do you need
maintain the safe house keep calms open
in case we need anything
you take care of the eclipse yeah
found a way to neutralize the dispersal
mechanism put in a hole blew it up and
bear the evidence
we knew I could count on you
next mission
you're with me in the field
Jupiter couldn't trust Venus or Neptune
to stay on track Saturn was the most
reliable option she had
all right here's the deal
I know you're Conley's guys I know you
answered to her but until this operation
is over
you answer to me and my crew I don't
want to have any problems
we have a long journey and a hard road
ahead of us but if we do this
if we get this right
we will be that much closer to
eradicating the disease once and for all
we're multiple reports of experiments
trying to weaponize the virus being
carried out with the blood of
asymptomatic carriers
we need to eliminate this threat
we're going to locate the labs samples
and these carriers to make sure the
green poison is destroyed once and for
all
their mission was to eradicate the green
poison
reports of experiments and weaponizing
meant though to focus on locating Labs
samples and carriers of the virus and
put an into it once for all
but with the introduction of the
cleaners to the team Jupiter found
herself in an argument with Venus
she expressed her concerns about working
with the phonetics and that she didn't
trust their intentions
particular Venus was having trouble with
the leader of the cleaner backup Buckley
I can't understand anything he says in
their stupid [__] mask
what's the problem
he doesn't respect me his team doesn't
respect me if they don't listen to me
they're going to get us all killed
you're exaggerating
I'm not Jupiter come on you know me
look I can talk to him but it's not
going to make him respect you you want
him to respect you
take care of it yourself
oh I'll take care of it I just needed
permission
Jupiter told her that they needed the
backup and that she needed to find a way
of working with them or that maybe she
just wasn't suitable for the job at hand
[Music]
so Venus took it upon herself to rather
than reason with the guy to instead
shoot him
dead
you told me to take care of it so I took
care of it
I meant talk to him not shoot him in the
head I did talk to him he yelled at me
and reached for his ax my response was
measured and appropriate
huh is that true
true enough
and now his team listens to me so see I
took care of it
you didn't take care of it you were
supposed to gain their respect not Their
Fear Venus they listen to you now
because they're afraid of you but it's
soon if they aren't afraid
you messed up
I thought you were better than this
Mercury
good to meet you Jupiter that was a trip
fine a couple of rough patches had to
put out a couple of fires you know the
usual everything set at the Docks
we should be good supplies are a little
low need to send a couple strike teams
out for food water and weapons but we've
got plenty of space and the boys are
looking for fuel you get me a list of
what you need and I can help you make
those strike teams
you're good
I'm efficient
Jupiter's team was now in DC
Mercury initiated his attack on multiple
sites including the Capitol building
Lincoln Memorial Space Administration HQ
and Air and Space Museum capturing a
number of the control points in between
while Neptune focused on the western
side of DC
Venus made moods in northeastern DC
capturing multiple sites of value in
downtown East Federal triangle and
Judiciary Square
while Saturn continued to hold down the
safe house in New York
One By One The Division was able to
locate the Rogue agents in DC including
Satan's whereabouts and lower Manhattan
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
eliminate them
while this was happening Jupiter was
still running point on the main mission
while a team was being hunted down and
killed by the division Jupiter was on
Roosevelt Island
she was securing a newly developed EMP
technology from a cargo plane that had
crashed there some time ago
combined with Vivian Conley's technology
these new EMP Jammers were able to
neutralize All non-rogue shd Tech and
completely removed an agent's armor
Jupiter's goal was to capture this tick
get it operational and ship it out to
Rogue agents Nationwide
this would [__] the remaining shd
agents around the country
the purpose of your team of agents and
the accompanying cleaners was to
distract the division while she prepared
Roosevelt Island
however the division reacted faster than
Jupiter was prepared for
the agents managed to overwhelm the
Rogues and push the cleaners Back to the
Island where Jupiter was forced to make
a Last Stand
she ordered the cleaners to utilize all
available EMP Jammers to put a stop to
the fast approaching agents
but it was too late
the division pushed through the defenses
destroying the emps and found themselves
face to face with Jupiter and eventually
after a long battle an embarrassingly
longer than I'd like to admit the agents
put a stop to her plans killing her in
the process
[Music]
accepted division this is a war you
can't win
kinger's Legacy will live on
I'd be dead if it wasn't for you I won't
let you down
not again
[Music]
having technically already died once one
of kina's lieutenants from the division
one is back and more loyal to keena's
cause than ever
Hornet kina's most trusted agent is
leading a cell of Rogues to fulfill his
legacy
but who are they and what are they
planning
in the early days Carter LaRue codenamed
Hornet had his entire career path
planned out for him by his parents
studying economics he was eventually
interning for the family firm
but after a short stint he felt
unsatisfied with this direction and
chose to sign up with the Armed Forces
Hornet joined the army and was stationed
in Djibouti Africa during this time he
met future rogue agent Aaron Keener and
they quickly struck up a friendship
becoming close Brothers in Arms
after he returned home family tensions
left Hornet feeling alienated and alone
he was lost and unsure of what to do
with his life next
after everything he had seen he just
couldn't return to a disc job
however he managed to keep in touch with
Kina who knew where he was coming from
and suggested he'd do something positive
with his life and sign up to the
division
Tina put hornet in touch with division
recruiter Elijah Lee who quickly signed
him up due to his capabilities and
experience
what do you think about catalaru Tina
recommended him said they grew up
together grew up together
his file says he grew up in Michigan
that's not exactly Jersey looks like
they served together in Djibouti figures
stick a bunch of guys in a room throw in
some guns and an existential threat and
the next thing you know they're all
reborn and calling each other brother it
says he volunteered for service that's
exactly what scares me he's a thrill
seeker Big Game Hunter former Futures
Trader sound familiar
what kind of person takes frequent trips
to Zimbabwe to slaughter two-ton animals
after returning from a war zone a person
who isn't afraid of a challenge or a
person with a taste for killing he
follows the law plays by the rules wants
to say we can't use that we can do with
a few more people like him to balance
the books a little if we're rubber
stamping this guy you're responsible for
him if he starts hunting again
however when Kina turned Rogue Hornet
was the first agent to answer his call
with their history he would continue to
follow kina's every move
after the second wave was activated
division agents were called upon to
retrieve the Russian virologist vitelli
trinenko in the Russian Embassy
Kina called upon Hornet to secure
tranenko before the division got to him
finding him locked up in a safe room
within the embassy Hornet used a
breaching charge to blow open a wall
while the division were on the other
side of the safe room trying to talk the
way in
the division pursued but Hornet managed
to extract the Russian scientists in a
helicopter before they caught up to him
in an attempt to stall the agents Hornet
stayed behind and engaged them head-on
the division managed to overwhelm and
take him down
leaving him for dead the division moved
on to return the information they'd
found on site to the base of operations
having been fed information from a man
on the inside Kina made his way to the
Russian consulate
outside he found Hornet severely injured
and dying
Kina brought him to Laurie Baker a rogue
agent and former Army surgeon who
managed to bring him back from the brink
of death
research it's okay I failed you forget
the consulate
you survived you didn't fail me
just a setback I'd be dead if it wasn't
for you your heart stopped for a couple
of seconds so you were technically dead
but termites good
brought you back if you boys are done
making out I'd really like to move this
location's not secure can you walk I'll
get it together you're stronger than
anyone could ever know
and I know
you will do great things I won't let you
down not again
the section only further enhanced on its
loyalty to Kina becoming his closest
Ally in the days to come
he vowed to do everything in his power
to help Keener on this mission
working behind the scenes Keener
eventually resurfaced with a new
variation of the virus that started it
all
with some of his Rogue agents he
attacked City Hall and lower Manhattan
while Kina hit the division's attention
he tasked Hornet with getting to
Washington DC and recruiting an army to
help with the cause
to help him get the job done Kenneth
supplied him with a number of eclipse
virus samples that he could use to
persuade any likely candidates
Hornet set up for DC along with four
other Rogue agents consisting of termite
Titan Luna and Huntsman
Laurie Baker codenamed termite was
trained as an army surgeon and took part
in a number of military conflicts
overseas
she was eventually dismissed from the
military after failing to follow orders
told to retreat during an attack on a
hostile base in southern Afghanistan she
instead opted to stay tending to a group
of wounded soldiers
but this impressed division recruiters
showing Independence and the ability to
make difficult decisions in high stress
situations
she was recruited and trained as a first
wave division agent
once activated termite was tasked with
securing a quarantine Center that was
set up by the government in New York
City
but after witnessing the effect of the
green poison she began to lose
confidence in the division's goal
believing that the only way to control
the spread was to eliminate the sick and
dying
not green poison we can't take any
chances the medical Wing is full we have
people sleeping in hallways and
bathrooms it's like
an incubation chamber and you can't stay
here I'm not gambling with her life if
we put her in quarantine with her immune
system compromised she won't make it a
week and send her on her way you can't
keep admitting people off the streets
like this I don't take my orders from
the division
she's staying the time to start
listening was yesterday if you keep
insisting on making the wrong choices
I'll have to make the right ones for you
they're weak they won't survive we can't
just leave them I'm not suggesting we
leave them what are you suggesting do
you really need me to say it say it it's
over the more we fight it the stronger
it gets there's only one option left you
sound just like those people out there
burning this city to Ash
we've seen this all before viruses
appear and spread But ultimately they
are defeated not this time
eventually the cleaners arrived to
cleanse the hospital
seeing this as an opportunity termite
disavowed the division
instead of holding off the attack she
killed a number of division agents in
jtf allowing the cleaners to break
through the defense in turn killing all
patients and staff on site
I'm impressed I don't have time for your
[__] Keener yeah it takes a
particularly strong or broken person to
facilitate Mass euthanasia you don't
strike me as broken
you understand what we're up against
listen if you're trying to get me to
repopulate the Earth with you you're
barking up the wrong tree oh God no
God no children for people with free
time and our time is limited if we don't
do something about it you have to think
about what kind of Legacy you want to
leave you've got something in mind oh I
got a plan
and I just need to know if you're
committed give me the elevator pitch and
I'll tell you we're going to eradicate
the weak
I'm in
Tina Solus is an opportunity to recruit
another agent to the cause
turmeric would later be responsible for
nursing Hornet back to health before
eventually heading off to Washington DC
on the recruitment mission
Tegan Silva codenamed Luna comes from
the security industry which is extensive
experience
she was working for the state department
in Washington DC when she was activated
her role was involved with closely
monitoring internal operations
but when President Ellis ordered the
jtf's withdrawal from the dark zone in
New York she began to lose faith in the
government's ability to control the
situation
you hear about New York there is a
massive outbreak in quarantine division
agents have been activated to assist the
jtf in regaining control of the city
yeah I heard the gtf pulled out [__]
decided they lost enough people built a
wall locked it down walled off the sick
hostiles if any agent foolish enough to
stay behind
they can't do that they can't just leave
agents to die apparently they can we
have to do something
we have to stop them who gave the order
Ellis
it's too late gave the order an hour ago
rumor is jtf moved out and the cleaners
moved in they're currently sterilizing
the area
sometime later after Keno went rogue and
started recruiting elani Kelso brought
Luna some encrypted Echoes to
reconstruct
these have been sent over by the
division in New York
hey Tegan you busy nope I've got time I
need you to work on some Echoes for me
you got the base data I can make you an
echo no no I don't need you to make me
an echo I need you to fix some okay you
have the files got a data transfer from
an agent in New York Lee Lao Lo
something like that she's been
collecting encrypted Echoes I was hoping
that maybe one of our techs could find
anything to help her identify or locate
these Rogues I'll do what I can Tegan
you're the best owe you a kermans
although Luna was tasked with tracking
the Rogue agents down she found herself
listening to a man who shared her views
becoming a believer in kina's vision for
the future she managed to create a
connection to the Rogue Network
frequency that he was using
[Music]
maybe 20 minutes you're lucky Alani
brought me your Echoes to crack
I've been listening
I want to help
how do I know I can trust you I have to
take my word for it for now that's all
I've got words mean nothing without
actions what can you offer you've seen
what I can do
the division still thinks I'm one of
them so you want to be my man on the
inside I do sir
I think it's criminal what they did to
you
no one can realistically think that the
way out of this crisis is to save what
remains I'm glad you understand what
we're trying to do here
there's only one way to end tyranny
Anarchy you're a smart cookie
Luna had become keena's agent on the
inside of the division and was able to
feed him Intel allowing him to continue
to be several steps ahead of them
it was Luna that informed Keener of the
division's operation to secure vitelli
trininko at the Russian consulate
this gave Kina the opportunity to react
and one Hornet of their approach
this warning however would ever finally
being flagged as a rogue agent
she would be reassigned to a position of
surveillance for kina's operation
Elijah Lee codenamed Huntsman worked in
the bomb disposal unit in Afghanistan
over time here in the Silver Star for
bravery
however after tripping an explosive
device one day he was given an honorable
discharge and spent a year undergoing
physical therapy for his injuries
later on he was hired by the division as
a recruiter in fact he was the one
responsible for hiring both Kina and
hornet
when the situation arose and the first
wave of Agents were activated Huntsman
used the opportunity to join them at the
field as an agent
but over time like many before him he
lost faith in the division's ability to
get on top of the situation and with the
deployment of the last man Battalion he
saw them as the ones who would be able
to get on top of the Anarchy that was
starting to unfold
fake
I'm doing this because the division is
failing right now the last man Battalion
has the best chance to take control of
this [__] show
besides I always look good in winter
camo
eventually the division took down the
last man Battalion leader Charles Bliss
and after his death Huntsman was left
not knowing what to do lost
of course thanks to Luna's Intel Kina
knew all about his situation and offered
him a job
Charles was a good man a good man don't
make it very far in this world what do
you want Tina to give you a job I've got
a job without Bliss your buddies want to
stick around
he'll join the next PMC to come along
and promise them a hot meal you know I'm
not like that I do
committed you're loyal
once you make a decision you stick
within decide to abandon it
kept pissing on your carpet [__] that
dog and the ex-wife he wrote in on
that's her problem now there's a western
problem
Karen died last week I guess there's a
silver lining where are you getting your
Intel I got someone in DC
Luna's got her ear to the ground and an
eye in the sky say hi hey hansman who
the [__] is Huntsman
you are
Jason buns codenamed Titan spent 10
years as a firefighter before gaining a
diploma in Wildland fire science and
training as a smoke jumper
after years of witnessing the
destruction of nature he became an
outspoken environmentalist
he was noticed by the division after he
survived for six days stuck in Wildland
fire that took the lives of the rest of
his unit
due to quickly spreading fires and city
parks Titan was recruited and then
quickly activated during the second wave
he didn't actually receive any formal
division training
we've got paranoid residents burning
everything in sight it's raining Ash and
the fire department's overwhelmed
there's no way inside unless you go in
from the top
think you can handle it I can handle it
what do you need from me you'll drop
down over Central Park we need you to
coordinate the trench build along the
perimeter what do you need from us a
pretty orange watch you're easy to
please just send a Helo and brief me on
the way thank you and welcome to the
division agent
after being treated for severe smoke
ventilation he was taken to a Sarah
hospital where he was surrounded by
victims of the green poison
he saw firsthand the destruction caused
by the virus
although Titan was injured he refused to
stay in the hospital
even with a nurse trying to stop him
Titan got as far away from there as
possible
I know you're only doing what you think
is right
and in some way I admire that
truth is
I don't understand what you're fighting
for and I don't think you do either
you call this a crisis
you think that death is a tragedy
real tragedy is how our innate desire
for survival overshadows our
appreciation for life
this is an opportunity
how much Devastation will it take to
realize that perhaps we are the poison
maybe it's time to accept our punishment
and
let nature decide what's best for the
world
this experience led him to question
everything that they were doing
as a true ego terrorist he began
wondering if this whole thing was
Nature's Way of trying to survive
[Applause]
seems like you're smarter than the rest
of us you didn't call to give me
compliments Keener I liked your
Manifesto gonna share my enthusiasm
you've got it all wrong sooner or later
we're all gonna die
I guess the real question is what do you
want to leave behind that's the point I
don't want to leave anything behind I'm
not even a legacy
green poison will run its course and
then the same people who trash this
planet will try to rebuild it and end up
destroying it for good
but with a little intervention you could
change that future
even though the goals were different the
methods of getting there were the same
Titan agreed to join Keener in his
Rogues and stop Humanity from continuing
down the same path they were headed for
the outbreak
once in DC Hornet set forth with the
recruiting
he saw the outcasts is a good place to
start since they were currently
leaderless and in need of a purpose
but they aren't exactly friendly to
strangers
however he had a different way of
getting their attention
people don't just drop dead like that
stay away from that smoke
all the clips don't [__] move careful
his watch is red relax
I keep my eyes open the gtf have been
causing you trouble thought I'd ease
that burden for you besides I needed to
get your attention somehow your people
aren't too friendly to strangers we
should kill him I wouldn't advise that
fear green poison is the only real
weapon you have and that won't last much
longer with antivirals starting to
circulate you've seen with the eclipse
virus is capable of and I've got plenty
to go around
it was around this time that the
division had caught up to Kina and after
Chasing Clues around southern Manhattan
they eventually faced off of them on
Liberty Island
where it was finally brought down and
eliminated
this led to in-house fighting between
Huntsman and hornet with Huntsman eager
to take over wekina liftoff and Hornet
keena's closest Ally having vowed to
keep things on track
sure
you're trying to make this power play
now that's just perfect
do you think you're half as smart as he
was oh I don't think I know and face it
kid you're not ready to leave this up
why don't you let the adults handle this
one senior left me in charge he trusted
me with the eclipse recipe you're not a
leader you're just running around
stinging my ass and you're just a creepy
ass spider hiding in the corner too
small and chicken [__] to do anything
regardless of how poisonous your bite
may be you've been working on that for a
while now kid haven't you fall in line
or get the [__] out
each one of Hornet's team of Rogue
agents split up to cover more ground in
DC
termites set off attacking multiple
sites including Bank headquarters the
Federal Emergency bunker Manning
National Zoo and Camp White Oak
while Titan focused on the western side
of DC including the Pentagon and DARPA
labs
Huntsman made Moves In Southeastern DC
capturing multiple sites of value in
Judiciary Square Federal triangle
Southwest and East Mall
while Luna continued to run surveillance
from Safe House in New York
One By One The Division was able to
locate the Rogue agents in DC including
Luna's whereabouts in lower Manhattan
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
take them down
while all of this was happening Hornet
was at Tidal Basin with his new Army of
outcasts as burkina's instructions he'd
been busy producing stockpiles of the
eclipse virus and was getting ready to
move out
the loss of his team of Rogues meant
that the division was quickly able to
locate him
the division assaulted the compound only
slowing down to avoid the pockets of
eclipse virus their Hornet had released
across the site in an attempt to block
and kill the agents
after fighting through waves of outcast
forces the division managed to destroy
the virus supplies
while frantically loading the remaining
suppliers onto the hovercraft Hornet and
his outcasts were attempting to escape
before the division were able to reach
them
but the agents caught up to him quickly
dealing to the outcasts and destroying
the samples on board
Hornet launched an attack on the
division
however they proved too much and were
able to bring him down and eliminate him
this time for good
time and time again the Black Tusk had
been hindering the Strategic Homeland
divisions attempts at regaining control
of the nation's capital
so it's finally time to remove the btsu
leader from the equation
but why does he suddenly have a bunch of
X division agents working with them and
what was with that Bloody hunter that
kept smacking me in the back of the head
while my back was turned
Barton Schaefer is the leader of the
black tusks specialist unit the btsu
he comes from a family with a proud
traditional and long line of military
service and at the age of 19 dropped out
of college and enlisted in the army
there he took no time at all and showing
an exceptionally High degree of skill
which resulted in a Swift and steady
rise through the ranks
Barton served multiple tours of Iraq and
Afghanistan
he quickly became known for his highly
technical way of assisting situations
and having the ability to eliminate
targets with extreme efficiency
later he was assigned to a Special
Forces Unit where he was involved in a
number of dark Ops before eventually
being approached by the Black Tusk
highly respected among his colleagues it
wasn't long before he was given the role
of specialist unit leader
he was given the task of gaining control
of Washington DC so his employers could
establish a new government
legitimately believes he is a true
patriot and that everything he's doing
is for the bitterment of the country
the division only answers to the
president but now that he is joined with
the btsu they no longer listen to him so
they're traitors
in his eyes the existing government is
corrupt and the division are nothing
more than a rogue agency
after the division discovered agent Lao
and cosworld had teamed up with Baden
they realized that his Threat Level was
only increasing regardless of how many
of his Ops that they were putting a stop
to
they needed to Target the man himself
but Barton had been busy and was
recruiting other division agents too
ones who had had a change of heart and
had turned their back on the shd
some of these Rogues included shade
wraith Dusk and belfry
named Shade was a parole officer in New
York City
and a large number of the people she
dealt with were released from Rikers
Island
after she was activated as part of the
second wave in New York City she became
aware of the horrific event that was
about to unfold when the call was made
to abandon the prisoners and leave them
to staff
she knew these people and what they were
capable of achieving just because
they're prisoners they shouldn't be left
to slowly die it would be kinder just to
shoot them
she had witnessed these people to great
things after their time incarcerated
some of them were good people that had
simply found themselves in the wrong
situations
some had been locked up for reasonably
minor offenses and were only serving a
term of 12 months or less
and some of them hadn't even been
convicted yet often these were the
people who couldn't afford bail who were
awaiting trial
not long after James dragoff the
division agent who'd killed the warden
on Rikers Island and then freed the
prisoners approached her
he asked for her assistance in
supporting his family of Rikers
she obliged and began working alongside
him in turn marking her as a rogue agent
prior to joining dragoff she had worked
closely with feylau and after dragoff's
death they introduced her to Barton
Shafer
you'll get the delivery tomorrow thanks
Schaefer you'll get that destabilization
you're looking for that's not the goal
shade we'll keep the division busy so
you can do whatever high level Espionage
it is you need to do if you're so smart
why the hell are you running with the
Rikers do you want to be on the winning
side right I want to be on the right
side
oh okay sure
not overly convinced by baden's claims
that he was fighting for the side that
was right she agreed to support him in
exchange for supplies that Iraq is
desperately needed
however gossip quickly started to spread
through the Riker ranks about how she
was working with Baden Schaefer
delivery tomorrow get a recovery team
together we get coordinates we're just
hoping for some [__] to fall out of the
sky we'll get them an hour before the
drop say for that way [__] I was joking
I heard you talking to Schaefer you
forget that name okay stop playing you
know what happens to people who play
with me sorry boss not today
codenamed wraith was a logistics officer
in the U.S army
after she left the Armed Forces she
returned home to Atlanta and found a job
a new field of expertise and started
working as a logistics officer for a
large Transportation Company
later on she was recruited by the
division and using the skills of her
trade she was activated to help keep
serious Supply loans operational at a
crucial point where the global economy
was starting to collapse
however at the same time she was
approached by the Black Tusk
she decided that this was the perfect
opportunity and went on to exploit and
control Supply to both the U.S
government and the global corporation
that is behind the Black Tusk
wraith is an opportunist and there's no
problem working both sides in order to
benefit herself
she is arrogant narcissistic and gutsy
enough to exploit two of the largest
most powerful organizations around
she is all about working the system
whether it be corporations or people
and when it comes to the hyenas they are
weak-minded substance abusers constantly
trying to get their next fix and she's
the one capable of fulfilling this need
in turn making them her puppets
she is very good at getting what she
wants
not long after going rogue her and Baden
made contact
Barton knew that wraith and the hyenas
would become a valuable asset in the
days to come so he was eager to win her
over in order for her to assist in the
operation
Lynette Edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation Marine
she had chosen to follow in her family's
tradition and pursue a military career
however it was a father that put in a
recommendation to the shd she was
recruited shortly after her first Tour
of Duty
dusk was activated in Washington DC but
it didn't take long for her to come to
the conclusion that the institution was
corrupt
in fact she was Finding herself more and
more aligned with the true son's way of
thinking than the shd
seeing all the tragedy caused by the
virus and how overwhelmed the jtf had
become dusk started losing faith in the
division's ability to save Washington DC
quickly came to the conclusion that more
drastic actions needed to be taken to
ensure their survival
as a strong believer in the need for
proper Authority and discipline in her
eyes the true Sons were the only ones
with the realistic and viable solution
to the situation
she eventually decided that enough was
enough she turned Rogue and joined up
with the true Sons
when the true Sons leader Antoine
Ridgeway was eventually hunted down and
killed by the division dusk went on to
continue ridgeway's work with a group of
true sons who were devoted to his cause
dusk is loyal patriotic and cares
greatly for a comrades
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on supplies
we need anything
rations
we hold out on the current stockpile a
week maybe more if we stop feeding the
privates I'll start eating rats before
we stop feeding our men
that's how you get a mutiny
she would do whatever it took to help a
new family even if it meant making a
deal with the Devil
dusk would use a context to gain a
connection within the Black Tusk and
offer a trade in return for food water
and weapons
Skyler Williams code name Belfry served
in the U.S army and was eventually
approached by the shd and recruited as
an agent
after retiring from the Army he went on
to become a local police officer in a
predominantly residential commuter town
following the outbreak he was activated
in his home state of Maryland but was
stationed at the Washington DC Sarah
camp and DZ South
but unfortunately it was his experience
in these camps that would change his
Allegiance
he witnessed the insufficiently tested
chemical called dc-62 being pushed into
these camps by the people who were
supposed to be protecting them
Belfry watched countless families
succumb to this lethal Yellow powder
gasping for air clawing frantically at
their throats while the toxic fumes
burned their lungs causing asphyxiation
and ultimately their death
cushioning his role as a division agent
feeling partially responsible and
equally helpless at the same time
he left his post in turn being flagged
as Rogue
eventually he made contact with Baden
where he would offer his assistance in
exchange for supplies
he was working to help other victims of
these quarantine camps the outcasts
got a new assignment sniper Duty no btsu
you're no assassin
boy you want to be a sniper now
pretty sure you need depth perception
for that gig wouldn't work even if you
had a robo eye I've seen you in the
field you like getting your hands dirty
no I don't
but I'm not afraid to do what's
necessary you ready to work directly for
the president for your country honey
what's funny he just promoted me to my
old job
the division was activated by the
president but as soon as they went
against him and your AI forgot to update
the line of succession you stopped
working for the president
the way I see it you and the Rogues
we've recruited are the only agents
still on Mission but that doesn't mean I
have to like it or you
button made it official by giving Fair
position within the btsu ranks her first
job to guard president Ellis
but the swear thing started to become a
little more difficult than he'd expected
the Rogue agents fade introduced to
Baden when exactly what you'd call low
maintenance
bringing them on board came at a
considerable cost and they were proving
to be somewhat challenging to work with
I need another delivery you know you're
not my only operator I know but I'm your
best
and if you want to keep me happy
find a way to get a delivery of tear gas
to Judiciary Square
the sooner the better whatever you need
Wraith
I aim to please that's my good boy
I knew you wouldn't let me down
get a crew together Supply or Combat
Supply got a new contact needs to prove
himself oh [__] we're getting helicopter
drones no I didn't ask for anything that
bad [__] too bad I could do some real
damage with one of those yeah pretty
sure you just get high and blow up
another Safe House
button obliged wraith's request he knew
she had substantial influence of the
hyenas and he needed them
they had a part to play in the upcoming
op
unfortunately wraith knew this and had
no problem testing how far she could
push things to get what she wanted
safer race what can I do for you now
yeah everything ready for your deadline
tomorrow good boy
are you sure you don't need anything
else just the tear gas
to test me I expected a test
you're still being tested
you haven't made the delivery yet
I value punctuality I'm always on time
we'll see
dusk contacted Barton and explained the
situation that her and the true Sons
were in
supplies were critically low and they
didn't have enough weapons to go around
button agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
would work together
what kind weapons or rations yes airdrop
or do you need a delivery Whatever Gets
my men fed and armed by tomorrow you got
enough ammo to take on hostiles one and
two squads then it gets dicey I can
arrange an airdrop and send coordinates
have your team there in two hours thanks
Schaefer no problem dusk
Schaefer how can I help you dusk I want
to let you know we got the supply drop
glad to hear it my boys are fed and
armed and ready to fight glad to hear it
what do you need wanted to set up a meet
what for I like to know who I'm working
with I always find a face to face tells
you so much more than a voice on the
radio fair enough whenever you're free
come meet me in Southwest I've got a
safe house there looking forward to
meeting you sounds good looking forward
to meeting you too dusk
however this was all getting a bit much
this budget was being strained and
resources stretched then
button started questioning whether these
Rogue agents were even worth all of this
Hassle and if they could even be trusted
he contacted Faye to discuss his
concerns
all these resources on the hyenas and
the true Sons dusk wants to meet up in
person now either she's got a crush on
me or this is a trap
how well do you really know these people
were working with
unable to get hold of Faye he decided to
take a step back and assist the
situation while dealing with other
pressing matters
but it was during this time that the
Rogue agents started to feel neglected
went to the meet but you weren't there
what happened sorry that
you're the one who wanted to meet and
you stand me up I didn't mean to
disrespect you I should have called but
these calms aren't the most secure and I
didn't want to give away your location
that's okay Schaefer this time you come
to me
it's too much of a pain in the ass for
me to get off the island name the time
and place I'll be there once you landed
two Bridges ping me and I'll send
coordinates
what is it Belfry you working with
Schaefer yeah you know I am what do you
think of them
very professional you've been getting
your deliveries yeah on time and info
[__] you're not
no
Cassie likes me better than you
dusk what is it Belfry what do you think
of Schaefer you like working with him
he's my [__] what's not to like you
getting your deliveries yeah he saved my
ass last week with a ration supply drop
[__] he blowing you off he's not
responding to my calls maybe he realized
your crazy ass was a lost cause and cut
his losses
thanks dusk hope he cuts you too
Schaefer this is Belfry come in what can
I do for you we're running low on
Munitions incendiaries and rations we
need a delivery yesterday I can get an
airdrop put together for you in two
hours have something to take care of
first just need a Drop Zone West End I
have a recovery team based there perfect
I'll put it together hold tight the
supply drop will be there soon don't
leave me hanging again I wouldn't do
that you can trust me
and as every parent knows when the kids
feel neglected they start to play up
um thing but you should really be using
Code or get us more secure channels I've
got to work with the tools at my
disposal
seems a bit Reckless
makes me worry about you Schaefer sweet
of you to worry you're sloppy
either you're trying to get yourself or
me Kilt
and if you're trying to get me killed I
hate to disappoint you but better men
have tried and failed race I'm not
suicidal and I know that your position
with the hyenas allows us to operate
more freely in DC I see your value I am
not sloppy but resources are limited and
we all have to make do with what we have
well done
you didn't yell at me you had a
reasonable answer for your way of
working and complimented me
well then
you passed the test
button is a patient man who had no
problem staying composed as he has dealt
with many challenging situations in his
career but he was starting to dealt
whether he could work with these people
unable to get in contact with Faye he
talks to someone by the name of Natalya
Sokolova
this is space chance to prove her agents
are worthy and our chance to keep my
business partners happy I think the only
thing she's proving is a division really
needed a better screening process you
brought her in her failures are yours
fix it
I do not tolerate failure I understand
it isn't clear who Natalia is to Baden
that she's certainly the one calling the
shots
she could be someone further up the
chain within the Black Tusk or maybe
even the main contact for the
organization that has employed them
button instructed shade to wreak havoc
on the division in New York City
she said to work attacking multiple
sites in the financial district Civic
Center and two Bridges
while wraith focused on the northeastern
side of DC including downtown west
downtown East Federal triangle and
Judiciary Square
dusk made Moves In Southeastern DC
capturing multiple sites of value in
East Mall Southwest and Capitol Hill
and Belfry directed his efforts towards
the west side of DC including the
districts of Constitution Hall Foggy
Bottom and West End but also New York's
Coney Island
One By One The Division was able to
locate the Rogue agents in lower
Manhattan and DC
although they put up a strong fight the
division agents were quickly able to
take them down
but this did include the assistance from
an unlikely foe
in each instance when finally able to
detect the location of the Rogue agents
a hunter would appear
interestingly he didn't seem to be
focused solely on the division agents he
was hostile to both sides of the
conflict
regardless having eliminated his Rogue
agents Burton Schaefer eventually made
his location known
he was on Coney Island
division agents had to navigate their
way through the amusement park which was
riddled with Rikers
yet a familiar face kept making an
appearance
the hunter that the agents admit time
and time again while disposing of
baden's Rogues was also there
and this Hunter was taken down Rikers
faster than the agents were able to
progress through the park whenever they
would get close he would vanish
over the comms Barton could be heard
telling the hunter to quit playing
around and kill the agents
and this is where the division met face
to face with the hunter that had been
following them throughout this operation
after a long dare I said couple of
attempts even the agents managed to take
down the Hunter
button updated Natalia Sokolova she
inquired of the hunter asset and when
button formed her that he'd been
eliminated she ordered him to clean up
his mess and finish the job
button instructed his group of elite
btsu operators to assemble and prepare
for the fast approaching division agents
but the agents made short work of them
and within no time at all barden's
guards were quickly disposed of
in a final offensive push Barton took
the fight to the agents and although he
was strong and put up a formidable
resistance they eventually managed to
take him down
Biden was critically injured but not
killed
a Halo was sent in to retrieve him where
he would be brought back to health and
then questioned on his knowledge around
the Black Tusk and the organization who
had employed them
Manhunt season 4 is now open and for the
first Target agents are tasked with
locating Bridget Douglas codename Viper
Viper brings some interesting additions
to the story including the first
confirmed Black Tusk recruitment from
outside of the US Military and a
possible link to other waves of division
agents that are yet to be activated
Viper is the only child of Charles
Douglas the co-founder of a military
equipment company
she grew up in a secluded luxurious
estate in the Scottish Highlands
after graduating from University Viper
completed an eight-year stint in the SAS
before taking a position in her father's
company Douglas and Harding as a
logistics and Supply specialist
however when the dollar flu outbreak hit
she was immediately contacted by the
Black Tusk yet this was after she was
recruited by the Strategic Homeland
division
completely disregarding her father's
opposition to the idea she joined up the
btsu shortly after
fast forward a few months feylau has
sided with Schaefer in the btsu
she was inducted into the group meeting
several prominent members and Viper was
among them
short you are impressive
you didn't have to join the services
rich girl like you had other options
just because my father has money it
doesn't mean I'm some spoiled rich girl
I can take care of myself your record
proves that
you joined the black task in December
that's correct before you were activated
I was never activated guess they're
still saving some of us for the real end
times does Schaefer know your division
he never asked and I didn't think it was
worth bringing up until it was a problem
smart
I like smart women me too
being that feylau was the acting
division commander in New York she would
have had access to highly confidential
Intel and was aware of Viper's
recruitment into the division
Viper was keeping this information from
Schaefer and she chose to hold this
information from him and less approached
about it
she'd spent her whole life having people
assume that she has it easy everything
given to her on a silver platter and
that she had no idea of the stresses and
complications that the average person
faced
but through issues with the father in
the early years she did it up most to
separate herself from the privileged
lifestyle and carve her own path and
this just happened to be in a direction
that her father wouldn't approve of
which probably only made the path that
much more appealing
following the outbreak Charles Douglas
can be seen talking to his business
partner John Harding
John for 27 years we spent building DNH
have you ever known me to be a paranoid
Lunatic Of course not but there is no
conspiracy Charles
everyone's just preparing all this Panic
will die down soon enough someone is
freezing us out
Supply militaries for God's sake if I
can't book factory time this company is
going down the path look forget about
this conspiracy theory of yours there's
no secret cabal trying to freeze us out
let's just focus on sorting out of this
mess I swear something big is happening
fine think what you want I don't have
enough energy to fight you on this right
now
with the current state of Washington DC
and the rest of America it was having an
effect on business with the closing down
of factories and inadequate numbers to
run them
Charles was certain that there was
something going on that was targeting
DNH weapons Manufacturing
however not long after this conversation
John Harding would pass away due to
complications from influenza
as the situation continued to get worse
in DC Charles eventually relocated to
the White House where he is working and
our users turn very Loosely as the range
officer in the shooting range
as a father Charles was very hard on
viper she found him a difficult man to
please who was constantly critical
towards everything she did and would
often downplay her achievements
this in turn resulted in her moving in
life directions that were against his
will
although this meant she was forced to
grow up to be strong and independent she
still Bears the scars of a very critical
upbringing
Viper doesn't think particularly highly
of the South and tends to be a little
insecure around her abilities
espresso machine ah well that sounds
like my dad he's doing great found a way
to make himself useful
he was lucky never caught the virus and
still has all his Parts aside from the
dandelion instead of his regular Kopi
Luwak it sounds like his life hasn't
changed much he's still in the lab
getting people to test his equipment and
probably making them feel really
insecure about their accuracy you miss
him
of course but when something like this
happens you have to do what you think is
right
I'm glad we each found something
even if he is actively making my life
harder
which yeah that hasn't really changed
much either
leading up to the operation Faye
discusses the role that Viper will play
I'm best in a support role you don't
want to lead your own team I prefer to
be in a support role I get that
some people aren't cut out to make the
hard choices oh that's not what I'm
worried about what are you worried about
being responsible for my team's life
you'll make sacrifices to save them
no
that I'll consider their deaths an
acceptable loss
we know what we signed up for we assume
this is a suicide mission if you make it
back home that's the unexpected outcome
you worried about survivor's guilt
can't be worried about something you
can't control and every Mission I come
back from I never feel guilty not about
being the one that comes back
other [__]
sure
but never that I survived
Piper isn't interested in leading a team
not because she's scared of the
responsibility more that she's worried
about treating them as expendable
the new career she was always aware of
what they were there for and that there
was a chance that they may never return
but in this situation the mean she would
lead would be relying on her to keep
them alive
regardless Faye pushed her out of her
comfort zone and assigned her a squad
how does it feel good
weird
I like being in charge but yeah it's
it's weird being the one people are
looking to for guidance
your team speaks highly of you Viper
you're a natural leader likable kind
tough when you need to be they respect
you but aren't intimidated by you
cool that's hard to pull off
especially for a woman thanks
I try not to be a [__] I'm still
working on that one
the Viper's surprise she was actually
quite suited to the task of leading a
team
she is a valuable and well-respected
leader
when instructed to do so Viper sit
fourth executing a part in the operation
taking a band of btsu she started
creating havoc in the southern districts
of Washington DC
multiple sites of Interest were captured
in West Potomac East Mall Southwest and
also the Pentagon
One By One The Division took back these
areas eliminating all black tasks who
engaged them
eventually they managed to catch up with
Viper
although she put up a strong resistance
the agents managed to put a stop to her
activities and take her down
in tune removing failures first
lieutenant from the field
it isn't clear what Viper's part in this
operation was but through continuing to
hunt down the remainder of the
lieutenants face plan and location
should hopefully become known
the latest Target in the season 4
Manhunt has confirmed a few suspicions
that have been discussed up until now
Felix sokolov has been reunited with the
sister and he is thrilled to be able to
grow and work together in a newly
acquired Empire
but does she share the same intentions
Russian businessman Alexi sokolov is the
founder and CEO of the hugely successful
International military equipment
manufacturer circle of concern
Elixir had a daughter to an earlier
relationship that separated later for
unknown reasons
he later married an American woman and
eventually they had his first and only
son Felix
as a family they decided to relocate to
his wife's country of birth the United
States but left behind his daughter to
keep the family business ticking along
her name was Natalia Sokolova
elixi was hard on Felix and had High
Hopes And expectations that he forced
upon him
as soon as he graduated from school
Felix was told by his father that he
must enlist with the Navy
while on deployment his father died and
his suspicious circumstances and after a
lengthy Court battle Felix's mother was
eventually convicted of his murder
when his tour was over he moved on to
study medicine at John Hopkins
University it was during this time that
he was recruited by the Strategic
Homeland division
but regardless sometime after completing
his study he was approached and
recruited by the Black Tusk
after her father's death and his
Stepmother's conviction Natalia reached
out to Felix
she went on to fund her studies and
attempt to reunite with the brother that
she barely knew
when bud and Schaefer brought felau on
board she met up with Felix during her
induction
you were a good Agent Felix what made
you leave the division family I get that
you lose someone my sister
the virus no Rikers
I couldn't keep her safe
budget cuts well you'll never have that
problem with black desk Natalia will get
us anything we need Natalia my sister
she runs this entire operation
anything you need I can get it
you don't think it's weird she'd let you
work in the field
it's not the safest place for a kid like
you you've read my profile you know I've
served before
that's why the division recruited me
well that and I'm sure they got a family
discount on those knee pads you were
wearing when Shaffer brought you in
it's unclear with the Natalia's name and
involvement with the Black Tusk was a
surprise to fail not but she didn't seem
overly convinced that Natalia's
intentions towards Felix were purely
about tight family bonds
you asking the other candidates this
much about their families only when it's
relevant so what else do you want to
know how close are you with your sister
not as close as I'd like
hard she grew up in Russia I didn't
really get to know her until after our
father died that was what six or seven
years ago six what does it matter
nothing just that's around the same time
she started black task so oh nothing I'm
just thinking out loud
it's interesting that your father dies
she reconnects or connects with you
she inherits the company and builds this
PMC it just seems like
never mind
I've seen conspiracies where they
probably don't exist my sister loves me
I'm sure she does when we lost our
father she was allowed to come from
Russia for the funeral it's not that
hard to understand that in that moment
she was there to help me she put me
through school she got me this job
she saw how agents were dying and she
sacrificed her men to bring me in and
protect me you'll do that if you don't
care about someone
Felix wasn't having a bar of it he
refused to believe that Natalia's help
was anything but family helping one
another
she offered him a role in the Black Tusk
after seeing how out of the dip the
division was
she rescued him from what was looking
like certain death
before the main operation fate talks to
Felix that escorting a VIP
Castro get your team ready got an
assignment nothing too big just need you
to escort a VIP babysitting Duty
seriously don't you have some grunts who
can do this trust me this escort is too
important to leave to a rookie well now
you've got my attention
given what we know about the black task
at this stage and who remains in the
ranks it's likely that this target is
prison Ellis or someone with equally
High importance to them so they needed
the right person for the job
leading up to the operation Felix
discusses strategy with Viper
had too many leaks she's smart to keep
this one close to the best do you know
who the target is I've got my suspicions
but I'm not going to speculate I think
it's Kelso okay Sparky don't strain that
big brain of yours
being young and eager Felix is Keen to
get started on the alt but expresses
confusion around the lack of Intel
Viper trust Faye and understands the
reasons behind the secrecy
unwilling to rock the boat Felix accepts
this and continues with his preparation
when instructed to do so he set forth
executing his part in the operation
taking his band of btsu he started
capturing locations of interest in the
northeastern districts of Washington DC
multiple sites were captured in downtown
East Federal triangle and Judiciary
Square
however the division were hot on his
tail and were quickly able to put a stop
to his advancements
after taking back these sites they were
able to find his location
while Phoenix put up a somewhat
unorthodox assault
[Music]
the division was eventually able to push
him back taking down his btsu guard and
eventually eliminating him in the
process
for the third target of the season four
Manhunt we come up against a rogue agent
going for the call sign Magnus
what information will we find towards
locating the division's second wave
acting Commander feylau
Dustin Xavier codename Magnus grew up in
Atlanta Georgia
a true patriot at heart he went on to
join the U.S military to do his part in
fighting for and protecting his country
during his second tour in Afghanistan
his unit was struck by an improvised
explosive device and they were ambushed
shortly after
showing extraordinary heroism during
this incident he later received the
valorous unit award
it was at this point that he was
approached by the shd and recruited
shortly thereafter
however it wasn't long before he started
questioning how well prepared the
division was with their mission
Xavier thanks it annoys me when people
don't know how to say loud but have no
problem with McGuire McMahon O'Shea and
Kavanaugh Fisher Schneider Muller might
have something to say about that Lucio
is German right very third generation
kept assistant his family was never
Nazis which you know
the more you protest the more likely you
are exactly that thing boys let's see
what a lady what she's won her unit in
Afghanistan yeah
you got hit by an IED
it happens any residual trauma just a
normal
got to make sure it wasn't for nothing
that's how they got me just in case we
need you to join us just in case most
likely you'll never be activated but
just in case
you survived the worst you can handle
this no one can handle this we're just
here to minimize the damage
and hope there's something left when
we're through
and if there isn't we will be the ones
to rebuild it
looking forward to working with you
Magnus
he came to the conclusion that the
recruitment process was more about
getting numbers and Ticking boxes rather
than being adequately prepared for such
an event to occur and this was only
further supported when you witnessed the
lack of equipment and resources
allocated to agents and how hugely
insufficient it was to handle the crisis
at hand
not long after his activation in
Washington DC Magnus was approached by
Baden Schaefer
you get it
get it Moses the power we have and I
know that we can't rely on the
government to save us the stain moves
too fast you have to be agile the wheels
of government rule too slowly for
something like this they're trying to
use a scalpel when what we need is a
sledgehammer I can be that hammer
Magnus immediately recognized an
individual with the same drive and
objectives as himself someone who only
wanted what was best for the country
so he would go on to join with the Black
Tusk
Magnus would later be assigned to
feylau's unit of Rogue agents but his
demeanor didn't exactly have him fitting
in with the rest of the team
Magnus
yeah I know what sup means hey hey you
don't mean nothing unless you want to
mean something gross hey you don't have
to be like that and you don't have to be
a disgusting human being but here we are
I hope you get eclipsed
that's [__] up I just said sup and you
wish that Keener [__] on me you're cool
Viper I thought we were friends
being a soldier was all he knew he was
just there to do a job and work with the
site that he believed had the country's
best interests at heart
he wasn't there to prove himself he
hadn't been impacted by the failure of
the government or the shd
he hadn't witnessed tragedy or lost
anyone close to him as a result
he simply found a team that he saw was
more aligned with his goals and were
better equipped to handle it
however some of the ways he approached
certain aspects of the organization
wasn't necessarily appreciated by his
colleagues
he just couldn't seem to comprehend that
he wasn't in the military anymore and
his new comrades from vastly different
backgrounds didn't seem to be overly
fond of his banter and the ideas that he
brought to the table
who better than the people in the field
the ones using the gear to tell you what
they want and need out of the gear fine
okay
so like stay with me think about it
think about what give me a second
okay picture it you're out in the field
you've got hostiles on your right and
left yeah so it's a Tuesday you see an
opportunity to run and slide into cover
but there's mud yeah some are in DC lots
of mud got it Tim you've only got one
pair of pants so what do you want what
if your knee pads had quick to flush in
and hip guards
not my sister to make knee pads that
have quick deploys sliding shin and hip
guards so you don't have to wash mud off
your pants yeah think how awesome that
would be yeah I'm not calling her for
that
the time came Magnus set forth executing
his part in the operation
taking his unit to the btsu he started
capturing locations of interest in the
western districts of Washington DC
multiple sites were captured in downtown
west Constitution Hall and East End
but as has happened time and time again
the division were there to stop the
Rogue advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any trace of his
movements in DC and eventually caught up
to him
taken by surprise you put up a valiant
fight but was no match for the agents
Cersei is the rogue agent credited with
converting feilau over to the Black Tusk
so with this in mind what more can she
add to the story behind the former
second wave Commander going rogue
Alicia cosworld call sign Cersei grew up
in Brooklyn New York
although she didn't come from money she
more than made up for it with
determination and dedication
Susie is a confident proud American
citizen with an optimistic and positive
attitude towards everything she sets her
mind to
after doing a tour in the Army she took
advantage of the GI Bill a law that was
introduced in 1944 that helps veterans
with the funding towards education
including college graduate school and
other training programs
it was during this time that she was
approached and then recruited by the
division
after graduating college Susie went on
to teach English as a high school
teacher and it was around this time that
the dollar flew was first released into
New York City
it wasn't long after she was activated
that she realized that the division was
hopelessly unprepared for the situation
they were facing
as a strong patriotic individual she
believed that the shd didn't have what
it took to get the country through these
difficult times
Cersei was eventually approached by the
Black Tusk having already lost faith in
the division it didn't take much
convincing to bring her over to this
side
sometime after the Black Tusk made
themselves known to the division and
invaded Washington DC Cersei was
captured by agent feilau
I know you're working with someone
careful Faye
you don't want to make Isaac upset
he hit me like that again he'll think
you've gone Rogue you teamed up with the
jtf we do what we have to you got a
concussion you're the one who isn't
thinking straight
what's your mission agent
to save what remains to ensure survival
that we live on that when we finally get
back on our feet there is something left
to stand on cool story Faye and how's
that working out for you it's hard
so we're stable sure for now
what about next week or the week after
or when you haven't had a Sarah delivery
for months and the medicine runs out and
the people who work together so well
right now turn on one another what are
you gonna do then Faye we will adapt we
will work together and find a way to
move forward and when they steal your
Tech and turn your turrets against you
what'll you do then Faye what I have to
Alicia I'm doing the same
you're not there yet but you'll see
we're the same I'm not like you I'm not
a traitor I'm not a traitor I'm
effective
I can see where this is going and who
can actually make a change
you'll figure it out eventually
or you'll die
either way my boys will find me soon
enough and then you'll need to make a
choice what choice is that to let me go
or see if you're good enough to take on
my team
who are you working with still haven't
figured it out
thought you were better than this I just
want to confirm it you scared never you
should be we took out the lmb I'm not
afraid of Black Tusk so you are as smart
as you pretend to be I'm a lot of things
you shouldn't underestimate me now tell
me about your first meeting with
Schaefer how do you know about Schaefer
Susie was surprised to learn that Faye
knew of Baden Schaefer had she too been
approached by him were they still in
contact
regardless Faye eventually agreed to
release her Cersei would regroup with
the Black Tusk although she was the one
being interrogated [__] had learned a
lot from their interactions
she sensed a certain vulnerability a
degree of doubt and FaZe eyes
Susie talked to Schaefer about the
potential of a new valuable asset
towards the black task cause
pretty sure she's an asset you think
she's ready she's desperate a little
push and she's one of us is that a good
idea no one has better access to the
division than Faye we bring her to our
side we'll know where all the bodies are
buried then it's just a matter of time
before they fall and we rise
although apprehensive about the idea she
ever takes cersei's feedback on board
and proceeds with plans to entice Faye
over to this side
sometimes past
the division is managed to locate and
eliminate keener's Rogue agents and
eventually the man himself
and this is when it was made known that
feylau herself has gone Rogue
I can't believe we're working together
again
sorry about the black sight I get it you
didn't know what this was you're right I
had no idea what this was
I'm starting to understand though
I'm glad you signed on
I always liked you Faye I like you too
Alicia
use my call sign Cersei makes it less
weird
Alicia's too personal reminds me of life
before this [__] fair enough you want to
call sign for this off no
it's better if I remember where I came
from
Susie confides in Faye welcoming her to
the team with open arms forgiving her
for a lack of understanding from the
earlier interactions
but it wasn't long before Shafer gave
Faye her own team to work with and one
of the first assignments she gave out to
Cersei was to get the location and
schedule of President Ellis
whose location and schedule do you need
chicken hawk that's need to know Faye
you know that
I need to know what do you want it for
just need to make sure that he's not in
any danger getting Rumblings about
transports and mobile units outside of
DC going through Maryland just want to
confirm that Chicken Hawk's not in any
danger
although suspicious of her reasoning
Susie gets her the information
really knows how to pick them hey he
picked me we're different his original
Squad completes [__] ups you're not
wrong how do you lose the Pentagon how
do you lose a bioreactor you know I
I still can't tell if it's incompetence
or a leak a leak someone on the inside
leaking Intel to the division why would
you say something like that makes more
sense than why we're losing the
antivirals and random agents getting
lucky wyvern wasn't stable in the best
of days for an Elite Squad our comms
should be secure we shouldn't be having
these leaks Isaac's good but he's not
that good there's no way that we should
be compromised like this maybe someone
programmed a back door into our comms
relay just pumping intercepted radio to
some data analysts in a basement under
the Lincoln Memorial makes sense Viper I
was kidding
Jesus you need to get laid you're wound
too tight
you might be right
but I wouldn't let any of these chuckle
Fox touch me they're not exactly my type
acknowledging the failings of sheffer's
original Squad [__] proclaims that this
time is different and when the time came
she set forth executing her part in the
operation
taking a unit of btsu she started
capturing locations of interest in
southern Manhattan
multiple sites were captured in Battery
Park the financial district Civic Center
and two Bridges
but much like the mini Rogue agents the
division have come across in the past
they were able to stop the Rogue
advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any traceable
movements in New York and eventually
caught up to her
Cersei put up a tough fight in fact it
took the agents A couple more attempts
than I uh they would ever like to admit
to
however in the end she was no match for
them and was ultimately killed in the
fight
was one of the division's most trusted
agents however permission to avenge the
death of his sister and rid the world of
Aaron Keener led her to going rogue in
joining the Black Tusk
but why did she choose to take this path
and betray the shd and her fellow agents
feylau is a second generation
chinese-american
when she was only 17 years old she
tragically lost both of her parents in a
car accident resulting in her being
tasked with raising her younger sister
hither on her own
records state that this changed her
certain behavioral traits including
Integrity accountability empathy
resilience vision and influence were
enhanced
resulting in strong leadership traits
that would assist her in the years to
come
however this also came at the expense of
her ability to gain and manage personal
relationships
while attending City College Faye joined
the school's Reserve Officers Training
Corps she used this to help further
progress her career
after a number of positions within
Military Intelligence fails eventually
admitted into the National Security
Agency where she worked as a part of the
support staff for the Director of
National Intelligence
after the presidential director 51 was
signed Faye relocated to the newly
formed Strategic Homeland division as a
senior field officer
she would be reporting directly to the
northeastern section division Commander
Lewis Chang
shortly after the first wave of division
agents disappeared president Waller
activated a second wave of Agents into
New York City and ordered Commander
Chang to personally lead the operations
fail was activated to serve as Chang's
seconded command but as the helicopter
was approaching its destination to pick
up Faye and the remaining agents of the
second wave it was shot down and
destroyed killing Commander Chang and
seriously wounding Faye
her injuries meant that she had to be
removed from field work
but as failure was now the most senior
agent in the city she continued to serve
as the acting division Commander
from here she was a primary contact and
strategic support for all remaining
second wave division agents in New York
months pass the division of made vast
steps in regaining control of New York
all major hostile faction leaders have
been killed in a number of parts of the
city were starting to rebuild
furthermore Intel suggests that the
first wave Rogue agents have left the
city along with their leader Aaron
Keener
more months pass
the divisions network was taken down and
protocol dictated that all available
agents must get to Washington DC as soon
as possible
but they made the choice to stay in New
York to stop them from losing the
foothold they have gained over the
months prior
there is an attack on the southern
Manhattan jtf Outpost at City Hall
Agents from DC are sent to investigate
they learned that the attack was
orchestrated by the rogue agent Aaron
Keener
it's now been over eight months since
the majority of the division agents
headed to DC and Faye had finally
recovered from her injuries
however something else was coming and
this would see Faye's whole world come
Crashing Down
a settlement in Hell's Kitchen district
has been attacked by Rikers
would near to no defensive systems and a
dwindling amount of jtf to properly
Guard and Patrol the facilities there
were massive casualties including face
sister
nevertheless with help from the division
Agents from DC she continues the hunt
for Aaron Keener
it was around this time that Faye
manages to capture a rogue agent who
just happens to be working for the Black
Tusk agent Alicia coswald otherwise
known as Cersei
the following weeks would see the
division locating and eliminating kina's
Rogue agents and eventually the man
himself
but even more shocking was the
Revelation from New York's number one
agent
Schaefer do you read
listening
far back kenner's dead
but he's activated the network
what's the damage
pernell's watch is collating the data
looks like it's all of them
[Music]
no
it's perfect
this will bring the division to its
knees
and that's when we'll end them once and
for all
although still apprehensive of the
decision to join up with a Black Tusk
Faye meets up with Baden Schaefer to
discuss plans going forward
how does it feel comfortable
relax personality though easier to spot
a friendly in the field the uniform
doesn't guarantee you're a friendly fair
enough
I like your style though no [__] I
think you'll fit in well here me too
do I get to build my team are you
testing me out with an established Squad
are you worried about getting hazed I've
had to break into boys clubs before
I know how you like to test people
finish this off and we'll talk about
building your own Squad copy that
over time Shuffle has eventually hunted
down by a former colleagues and captured
Faye took little time in organizing a
meeting with President Ellis
to shape history I couldn't agree more
Mr President you said it yourself
somebody has to step up I'm willing to
take on that challenge if we're going to
get this country back on track we have
to be willing to do things that won't be
popular
that you and Shafer had a rather
contentious relationship
Liberation will be more efficient
I look forward to meeting you in person
you arranged
see you soon Mr President
what an [__]
after finding out Alice's whereabouts
and schedule they caught up with them at
Camp White Oak
and when the time came without
hesitation she gunned him down where he
stood
meeting adjourned Mr President
done
at this point in time division agents
were already hot on a trail
but she had already ranked through
announcing that it was a division that
had taken the president out so time was
of the essence they needed to catch up
with her before they too were announced
as Rogue
chasing her through the compound they
eventually caught up with her in the
area that Alice himself had once escaped
the grasp but this time they were
prepared
disabling the helicopter fails forced to
engage the agents head on
after a short fight the division was
able to eliminate her supporting btsu
forces
although Faye certainly brought the
fight the shd agents had no problem
bringing the full force of their
Vengeance to the party
[Music]
let's face it I haven't heard from a
single person that wouldn't agree that
this was a disappointing end to the
Manhunt but based on the trailer and the
sudden announcement from massive that
this was to be the last update to the
division 2. I think that this isn't the
last we're going to hear of feylau
I legitimately believe that we were
supposed to capture Fey similar to what
we did with Schaefer
but due to the apparent unexpected
decision to extend the division over the
next year or two they potentially cut
the final cinematic to be expanded on
later
this could also be further supported by
the fact that Isaac never said anything
of substance when she was dropped but if
Theo taught us anything Isaac can be
easily manipulated so who knows however
for now let's look at the facts that
have been presented to us in game
Faye lost his sister due to an adequate
jtf resource to look after the
settlements
fake captures and interrogates Cersei
Aaron Keener is killed followed shortly
after with Faye being found out as Rogue
Barton Schaefer is captured by the
division
Fey locates prison Ellis and executes
him blaming it on the division
Fey is found and potentially captured by
the division
then there is the last comms that we
received from this Manhunt that leads to
the idea that Fey is working as an
undercover rogue agent
you probably never liked me and only
moderately tolerated me
it's okay that's okay
we didn't have to be friends
and I know you probably think I'm a
[__] that you would never actually say
that
that's my face at least
I think the reason we never really got
along is we're too similar
stubborn we care too much and frankly
we're both pretty guarded people
we've both lost people
and we didn't deal with that as well as
we could have I guess but I hope that
when I'm done you'll understand why I
did what I had to do
I don't expect you to agree with it but
I hope you understand
I'm not sorry I went down like this but
I'm sorry I couldn't tell you why
hey Roy
this is hard for me
this is probably the hardest thing I've
ever had to do
you trusted me and I loved you for that
it broke my heart having to keep secrets
like this from you but I knew I knew if
I told you what I was planning you would
try to stop me
and if you tried to stop me there was no
way I could have gone through with any
of it
there's no way I could have interrogated
Alicia or met Schaefer or gone with him
I had to do this Roy I had to
we were losing we lost the authority we
lost the trust of the people we were
trying to protect without trust we have
nothing it doesn't matter how many good
or bad things we do if no one trusts you
to get the job done it was Schaefer and
Ellis we lost the legitimacy we lost the
ability to say we are on Mission hell
the only one who agreed we were still on
mission was Isaac
I knew what I had to do all I needed was
access and I couldn't get that unless I
joined them or at least unless I could
make them believe I joined them
I'm sorry I couldn't tell you why
sorry I had to break your trust like
that
but I hope I pray you'll forgive me
someday
if you don't I might have to come haunt
your ass until you do
while out
though if this is true and she is simply
going through all of this to take down
the Black Tusk asset prison Ellis why
did she blame his death on the division
this leads me into two different trains
of thought
Ellis is the one responsible for having
the gtf abandoned the quarantine Zone
not long after the initial outbreak
this in turn led to many division agents
going rogue with one notable agent in
particular Aaron Kina
Fey blames Kina for his part and the
death of her sister and Alice's part and
putting Kina in that position
the division is the last organization
with any ties to the Old Government
given them claim to determine what's
right and wrong
it's no secret that Faye isn't a fan of
the way that Isaac operates but
considering everything that's happened
perhaps Fey has finally lost hope in the
government in the shd2
she has come to the conclusion that this
Strategic Homeland division is a failed
initiative and that with all the freedom
they are given they still don't have
enough wriggle room under the guidance
of Isaac to do what is needed
I don't necessarily think she believes
the black task of the answer but now
that Schaefer has been captured she
decided to seize the opportunity and
kill two birds with one stone
she would execute Ellis and bring down
the shd
as witnessed in Walled of New York at
the Haven settlement trust in the
division is already pretty low the
general public is sick of watching these
agents do what they want and eventually
turning Rogue and working against them
with Faye blaming the death on the
division that should be enough to push
the remaining settlements over the edge
and without the support of the people
the agency would collapse
this would basically put the division
agents in a position of becoming Rogue
agents with the risek has flagged them
as Rogue or not is redundant in the eyes
of the people they are no longer allies
put in place to save what remains
however I don't think having each of the
agents hunted down and killed is what
Faye actually wants
this is likely just a side effect of
what she has done
she may have just deemed this as
acceptable collateral damage an omission
of putting the final nail in the coffin
of the old U.S government and the shd
in fact maybe she was hoping that they
would regroup with her later on no
longer under the shd control
[Music]
alternatively the second and probably my
preferred Direction
Faye hasn't lost hope in the government
and she still strongly believes in the
division's mission of saving what
remains
but over time watching this determined
and well-funded new enemy and the
remaining agents around her either being
killed or turning Rogue joining the
Black Tusk ranks she has come to the
conclusion that they are fighting a
losing battle
the only one left in the government is
corrupt and is joined the other side the
chain of command is already broken
it was up to her to take him down before
he was used to bring the general
populace over to their side
Faye would go undercover and eliminate
Ellis after gaining their trust
she had to do this alone firstly she
didn't know who she could trust anymore
and those she could like Benitez
wouldn't allow it to do this on her own
but she had already lost enough loved
ones and didn't want to be responsible
for more of the deaths on her hands
the reason she blamed Alice's death on
the division agents was to keep a cover
from being blown
after all Schaefer had already been
captured but Natalia Sokolova was still
out there and while she was still around
the Black Tusk are a threat to the
country
yes this means that division has now
been burned but as she had seen him as
only losing ground to this invading
force it was a sacrifice she had to make
on top of this given that they are now
Rogue agents she may be able to bring
more of them undercover into the btsu to
help her Mission especially once Benitez
and Rhodes receive a message
feylau decided that it was up to her to
do what no division agent was able to
and that the only way to do this was to
go Rogue join up the Black Tusk and take
Ellis and the rest of his leadership
down from the inside
seasons 5 6 7 and 8 are just repeats of
seasons one to four but not in the same
order which is a little bit weird the
only reason I'm including the section in
the video is to explain why the content
I'm about to run through jumps from
season 4 to season 9.
well it looks like the true suns are
getting Bolder under their new leader
General Anderson he used to be a
strategist for Ridgeway and it looks
like his ambition has reached New
Heights he's smart they're keeping him
at a secure location we're getting
reports of five of his true Sons Moving
on DC
major Castile a civilian turned true son
Castillo's background is in engineering
he's been taking over radio frequencies
and broadcasting these rants that
frankly if you didn't know better could
be quite the recruiting tool
Sergeant Daniels this woman is a piece
of work or getting reports of her
indiscriminately assassinating civilians
in the street she's on a rampage
we've also got a logistical Nightmare on
our hands with Lieutenant Chang his
background and experience has shored up
the true Sun supply lines and weapons we
can't afford to let him build their
stockpiles
then there's major Xander she has some
anger management issues Xander's been
torturing and interrogating civilians I
don't know what she's hoping to learn
from them but we can't allow her to
carry out this Inquisition
and last but not least is Captain Lewis
we haven't actually seen him in DC yet
but we've intercepted comms that imply
he and General Anderson are planning
something big
agent you know what to do
Malcolm Castillo was the senior engineer
at the pentco Fairview Nuclear Power
Plant
expecting his first child with his wife
Sharon the prospect of the future was
both exciting and daunting
he'd always been very particular about
how things should be done and when it
came to Preparing the house for the
arrival of their new baby this was of no
exception
Castillo had a plan and this would be
one of the major contributions he could
actually do for his expectant wife and
he was eager to get started as soon as
possible
so for the sake of their marriage and to
avoid any more unnecessary stress Sharon
had decided that at five months pregnant
it would be a good time to visit her
family in New York
this would also be one of the last times
she would be completely Child free in a
Black Friday shopping spree with her
sister in Manhattan sounded perfect
the plan was simple she was to spend two
weeks bonding with her sister while
Castillo focused on getting the house
ready
unbeknownst to her and the multitude of
Shoppers on Black Friday a deadly virus
known as the green poison had been
released and sadly while out shopping
Sharon 2 contracted the virus
assuming that it was no more than just
the flu she refused to seek treatment
her main concern was that the doctors
might prescribe her something that could
harm her unborn baby
ten days later
at a clinic in Brooklyn
Sharon died
utterly broken and grieving the loss of
his wife and unborn child Castillo
immersed himself deeply into his work in
the hopes of keeping his mind busy
eventually he moved himself into the
facility to ensure that the plant
remained functional at all times
as the pandemic continued to progress
the National Guard was ultimately sent
in to protect the compound in an order
for Castilla to remain on site he would
have to enlist
even after completing basic training his
primary objective still remained the
same as the on-site expert he was to
continue in his role of keeping the
power plants safe and operational
however always there and in the back of
his mind he believed that Sarah the jtf
the government and in turn the division
were all heavily responsible for what
happened to his family
he held the belief that there was no way
possible that they were unaware of
amherst's plans and that they simply
just allowed it to happen
Anderson who was a logistics officer to
the leader of the true Sons Antoine
Ridgeway was successfully able to tap
into Castillo's grief along with further
heightening his mistrust of the
government
by using Castillo's anguish and genuine
experiences to express his deepest
heartbreak Anderson was able to convince
the National Guard to abandon their post
and thus allowing the true Sons to take
control of the plant
nice to meet you guys
because I could say the same dusk excuse
me I don't care if your watch is red
your Division and now you're working
with the black dusk I can assure you I'm
a true son then why are you still
wearing that garbage the best way I can
support the true Sons is to take
advantage of the existing infrastructure
I thought that was something we had in
common you're smart so are you
and we are specialists in our fields as
long as you are loyal to Ridgeway
to the cause
I promise to keep you safe you really
are a true son I am
Now give me the tour I've never been to
a power plant before do I need to wear
like a lead-line suit or something only
if you go near the reactor or your
radiation meter goes into the red but
that won't happen
Lynette Edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation Marine
shortly after her first tour she was
recruited by the shd
after the outbreak dusk was activated in
Washington DC but it didn't take long
for her to come to the conclusion that
the institution was corrupt in fact she
was Finding herself more and more
aligned with the true son's way of
thinking
eventually she decided that enough was
enough she turned Rogue and joined up
with the true Sons
when the true Sons leader Antoine
Ridgeway was eventually hunted down and
killed by the division dusk went on to
continue ridgeway's work with a group of
true sons who are devoted to his cause
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on suppliers
she would do whatever it took to help
her new family
dusk would use her contacts to gain a
connection within the Black Tusk and
offer a trade and return for food water
and weapons
button shaver would get in contact
she explained the situation that her and
the true Sons were in supplies were
critically low and that they didn't have
enough weapons to go around
Baden agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
could work together
with all of this happening Castillo
would keep on working tirelessly to keep
the power plant operational while also
continuing to obsess of the events that
led to his wife's death
Castillo we've been having rolling
blackouts everything stable with the
grid nothing is stable with the grid
everything is old and failing that's
comforting should I be looking for a
fallout shelter everything is stable
with the reactor the reactor and the
grid are two separate things trust me if
the reactor failed you'd know oh well
you're the expert your local power
supply has nothing to do with our work
here if you're having rolling blackouts
brownouts or unstable power you're going
to need to send someone down to the
relay stations and Transformers and see
if they need maintenance I'll see if
I've got anyone who knows that
infrastructure good luck
start with X Public Works employees or I
guess raid the secretary of the
interior's office for a map of the power
stations you're funny I'm serious go to
City Hall they should have schematics
for all of this stuff
it should also be online your precious
Isaac should have all that data
you should be an agent I'm happy being
an engineer I don't need to play Sheriff
it's probably squatters someone Taps
into the line doesn't know what they're
doing and [__] up the whole system
you'll need to check the stations then
you need to send the exterminators to
take care of the rats chewing on the
wires
should be like riding a bike for you
after some time it passed and the leader
of the true Sons Antoine Ridgeway was
killed by the division and in dusk
during the badon Shafer Manhunt General
Anderson would step up and take the
reins
Anderson had ambitious goals for the
true sons and plan on expanding their
reach far beyond Washington DC
it was around this time that Castillo
had decided that it was time for him to
put down his work and investigate
further he wanted to go into DC to find
out more and who was responsible
but without him on site there would be
no one to run the power plant
so Anderson made a deal with them to
train up true Sons members to work in
his place while he was gone
how are the new recruits doing great
we've got four shifts 10 people per
shift 40 skilled prisoners trained and
ready to operate the reactor in case
anything happens to me
each shift has a true Sun at the helm to
keep them in line and train any future
Replacements and each of them has two
backups
are set for the worst case scenario
and the best case best case if we want
to expand our operations we have the
opportunity to build a mobile team to
take control over another reactor
the infrastructure design and basic
mechanics are similar enough the my crew
should be able to figure out how to keep
the lights on that's excellent news
Castillo thank you sir
about that favor you've more than earned
it transpose on their way you will have
a squadron at your disposal
good luck in DC I hope you find what
you're looking for
thank you sir
after training enough true Sons to run
the plant General Anderson rewarded his
dedication by sending him to Washington
DC to investigate Sarah in the
division's role in his wife's death
but Anderson had ulterior motives behind
this gift having already used Castillo's
speaking talents to gain control of the
power plant without Bloodshed previously
he saw a powerful propaganda machine
that could be placed in the middle of DC
there he could continue to bolster the
true Sun's ranks or at the very least
provide a much needed distraction
it was a win either way in Anderson's
eyes
and
my daughter
foreign
after taking back a number of strategic
points of interest Castillo and a group
of true Sons would eventually be tracked
down and confronted by division agents
in the DCd headquarters
there he would face off against the
division agents eventually being brought
down and killed
Michelle Daniels her great-grandfather
was a proud confederate soldier her
grandfather an army man her father an
army man and her brother an army man
a proud and male dominated family with
deep roots entrenched in patriarchy and
service to their country
the lots of her mother during Daniel's
birth meant that she never truly had a
maternal figure to help advise and guide
her while growing up maybe the softness
of a mother could have shaped her
differently made her gentle and possibly
even meant a different path a new life
yet irregardless she grew up tough she
had a hardness about her that even the
boys left
she was gritty callous and at times
indifferent and cold
taking a life was easy there were never
any regrets and why should there be it
was her right she was an apex Hunter
others noted with alarm whose seemingly
dismissive nature in regards to taking a
life when she fished when she hunted and
that sharpening her rifle skills was
more important than anything else
yet her father always insisted that
Daniel's demeanor was just the result of
not having a mother growing up around a
multitude of males in adopting a tomboy
attitude in order to survive
contradictory to her father's efforts in
stopping the rumors Daniels never felt
she needed to justify herself
her attitude had always served her well
in the past and this proved successful
in the Army as well and she took immense
pleasure and testing and pushing the
boundaries of new recruits to see if she
could break them
unsurprisingly her actions were noticed
by her superiors and as a result she was
repeatedly written up for objectionable
Behavior Unbecoming of an officer
after serving in one tour she returned
back to her life and Hometown as
civilian there she began to work for her
father in his tackle shop and hosting
guided fishing tours on the Potomac
River
unsatisfied and discontented with this
lifestyle a year after leaving the Army
she enlisted with the National Guard in
the hopes of finding some excitement and
to Stave off further boredom while also
continuing to work as a river guide
with the outbreak of the deadly virus
the National Guard was activated in
Washington DC and she like so many
others would eventually be merged into
the jtf
anything and everything necessary to
save what remained Daniels was undaunted
by the task and ready to get to work
but eventually she became aware of
Antoine Ridgeway his ideals and his
loyal men the true Sons
this was the moment she'd been training
for
finally a leader who wasn't afraid to do
what was necessary someone she could
admire
who would appreciate her strengths and
recognize her indifferences towards
others and death to be assets rather
than liabilities
not long after agent dusk defected from
the division she met Daniels and they
would become strong allies and Friends
after Antoine ridgeway's death when the
true Sons were demoralized broken and
severely short on supplies and weapons
dusk made contact with Schaefer to
negotiate the terms of him providing the
true Sons with support
nervous about going to meet him alone
dusk reached out to Daniels for backup
just to Sergeant Daniels come in Daniels
this is Daniels what can I do for you to
ask you free tomorrow not really what do
you need I've got to meet with Schaefer
he didn't show for the last one
something feels off could really use
someone I trust to have my back all
right I thought you wanted alone time
with your boyfriend Rose gross I don't
know what Faye's thinking working with
him I don't know if I could trust this
guy ah he's black task but he's a boy
scout we talking about the same Schaefer
do you want that backup or not better
safe than sorry I can't make it but I
can lend you a couple of cards thanks
Daniels I owe you one more like 20.
in order to get the food and the
equipment for a true Sons to survive and
rebuild dusk would have to join Schaefer
on an operation he would soon be
carrying out in DC
Dusk and a god of true Sons were to run
point in the Southeastern districts of
the city capturing multiple sites of
interest in East Mall Southwest and
Capitol Hill
But ultimately this was a suicide
mission merely a distraction
dusk in her accompanying true Sons would
one by one be hunted down by the
division and eliminated
and eventually even Schaefer would end
up being captured on Coney Island
Daniels took the loss of a friend very
hard and demanded Revenge so she
approached General Anderson for orders
on how to proceed
uh negative Daniels but she was one of
ours she was a true son she was a rogue
agent first she was one of us but she
was also one of them and loyalties as
fluid as dusks there's no way to know if
she was playing her own angle no no no
no I sent my men with her and in time we
will avenge them but not to
we need to see how this plays out
Shapers to blame General we don't know
that for sure but I will look into it
personally we can't keep working with
the Black Tusk
they're a liability you may be right
there are too many Rogues in their
organization
who knows what they're really planning
and with Ellis in their pocket
proceed with caution
General Anderson simply brushed this off
as an acceptable loss to him dusk was a
turncoat and would have more than likely
done the same thing to the true Sons
when it suited her Yeti did agree that
working with the Black Tusk was
potentially the wrong direction going
forward
after the death of felau at Camp White
Oak Sergeant Daniels was sent by Captain
Lewis to Washington DC as part of his
specialized team
there she seemed to be looking for
something as reports indicated a
multitude of Civilian interrogations
acted out by her personally
but it would seem she wasn't getting the
outcome she needed
Lewis said I should talk to you
I want permission to use
Advanced interrogation techniques
sergeant I know that if I can push them
a little harder I can get them to tell
us what they know about the house I
don't need my permission to do what you
feel is necessary I trust your judgment
thank you sir if your methods produce
results that's all that matters oh I'll
get the answers we're looking for thank
you for being so thorough a true son
leaves no stone unturned we'll root out
these snakes
Anderson was happy to oblige especially
if it would get the results that the
true Sons needed
however these are the actions that would
put Daniels on the division's radar
agents would catch up to Sergeant
Daniels in downtown west where she and
her true Sons had set up a stronghold
capturing strategic points throughout
the district
one by one they were taken down and at
the bank headquarters division agents
and Daniels meant face to face
although she was well defended and her
troop of true Sons fought hard the
agents were able to persevere and fight
through
and eventually take her down
Mackenzie Chang is a third generation
chinese-american who was born and raised
in Washington DC
his father and his mother's father were
both in the Navy and so like them Chiang
2 wanted to follow in their footsteps
enlisting at 18 He soon discovered that
it wasn't the right fit for him
he hated the water and found the Navy
and their rules when not to his liking
he ended up being placed in the ground
transportation team and there he felt
his time and skills were being wasted
eventually things came to a head when he
got himself involved in a bar fight and
as a result he broke his arm and three
ribs
with a year still left on his contract
his family were able to pull some
strings and fortunately for him they
were able to get him an honorable
discharge from the Navy
he returned to civilian life and got a
job as a museum security guard within
the local mall
yet he soon realized that being a
security guard at the Museum was not as
exciting as he thought it would be and
began to miss regular combat trials
he endeavored to get some of that
adrenaline rush back so he tried his
hand at Airsoft and hunting
yet these two also lacked the luster he
was after
finally he joined the National Guard in
hopes that this would bring some of the
action he was longing for
when the National Guard was eventually
called on to secure the mall against
peaceful protesters Chang saw this as an
opportunity to use his previous
knowledge and expertise as a mall
security guard to set up the perfect
perimeter
General Anderson was impressed by the
initiative Chang showed and immediately
took him under his wing and Logistics
not long after the death of Antoine
Ridgeway Anderson gave Chang his own
unit
however he denied him the promotion that
Chang so desired and becoming Captain
until he could prove himself as a worthy
leader
Chang is unwavering and his
determination to demonstrate that he is
deserving of the leadership role and
ready for the title of Captain and the
admiration of General Anderson
General Anderson I just wanted to send
my condolences about Dusk and her team
thank you Shafer moving forward is there
someone else you'd like me to work with
that won't be necessary
the division has control of your supply
routes in DC how do you think you'll
survive without our assistance well
Lieutenant Chang has more than enough
experience organizing transpo and supply
drops we no longer require your services
as a glorified errand boy I think you're
making a mistake I've only made two
mistakes in my life the first was
trusting loud the second was letting her
bring you into our operation good night
Schaefer
after agent dusk's death sheff would get
in contact with General Anderson
with everything that had gone down they
were no longer willing to work with the
Black Tusk
Rogue agents Hunters that seemed unable
to be controlled in a leadership who are
working under their own hidden agenda
Anderson decided that it was no longer
in the true Sun's best interest to be
working alongside them
anything they had gained from working
with them was more than being made up
for by the work Lieutenant Chang was
doing in logistics
bud and Schaefer would leave a message
with Natalia Sokolova to update her of
the situation
Natalia Schaefer just got off the horn
with General Anderson he's decided Black
Tusk supplies and assistance are no
longer required
true sons are on their own in any
tentative piece we may have broke it has
been severed by the death of Lynette
dusk Edwards
I'm not comfortable working with the
hunters
this Arrangement is creating more
problems and we are losing allies
this is not why I joined the Black Tusk
Schaefer voices his concerns
he explains the agent dusk's death
seemed to be a large part of this
partnership breaking down
but that the hunters are his biggest
problem
they can't be trusted
the jeopardizing the mission
this is not what he signed up for
Schaefer would eventually be contacted
by Lieutenant Chang
ER this is Chang come in good to hear
from you lieutenant you change your mind
about working together no so this is a
social call dusk was a good woman and a
damn fine Soldier I know here's going to
meet you and you got her killed you know
that was beyond my control you weren't
even there you left her to die
you're right I wasn't there we've run
into some complications what kind of
complications there was another player
on the field what the hell are you
talking about those division agents
weren't the only ones targeting her you
make it sound like she was being stalked
or Hunted
Jane just wanted to give Schaefer a
piece of his mind wanting him to answer
for what he did to dusk
Schaefer agreed that he'd lit it down
but that there were unexpected
developments that someone who had been
brought in to help instead
how to do down
after feylau's death Captain Lewis sent
Chang into Washington DC as part of a
specialized team
his job was to re-establish the true
Sun's transportation and supply chain in
the area
however after capturing a number of
important locations in the Foggy Bottom
District he would quickly appear on the
shd's radar
after battling through Chang's countless
number of true Sun soldiers they would
eventually catch up to him in a Potomac
Event Center
with the division agent Superior
training it wasn't long before
Lieutenant Chang liked so many before
him was eliminated
Amanda Zander only wanted one thing in
life the opportunity to become a police
officer it's all that she'd ever really
dreamed of the desire to uphold the law
and an eagerness to bring Justice and
order to the people
she possessed a high level of dedication
and skill in her work in the narcotic
sector and nothing felt better to her
than identifying a potential Target and
hunting them down
police work wasn't all that she'd
thought it would crack up to be as most
of the time it was a waiting game filled
with endless paperwork and copious
amounts of cream-filled donuts
she knew she had to find other means of
entertainment to make up for a
lackluster career so she joined a
competitive shooting league
yet Xander was still not content with
this situation
she could be a dangerous person at the
best of times and especially when she
was bored she knew it her family knew it
and recently due to the use of excessive
force on a perpetrator now her superiors
knew it too
unsurprisingly as a result she was
sanctioned
she was annoyed at herself and she knew
she had to get back on track and channel
her impulsiveness into something else
there was still so much Glory up there
for her to grasp and she knew that
alarming her superiors so early on in
her career was not the way she was going
to get it
in order to help her direct her energy
into something more constructive her
commanding officer recommended that she
sign up for the National Guard
The Hope was that the intense training
schedule strict rules and very little
downtime would help curb her impulsive
and trigger finger nature
however a month later the devastating
green poison was delivered onto the
unsuspecting Shoppers of New York City
on Black Friday and from then on
everything for Xander would change
she along with a number of other
Personnel were placed on active duty
with the jtf and it was here that a man
by the name of Antoine Ridgeway would
become her commanding officer
here in this environment Xander's
Psychopathic traits of anti-social
Behavior lack of empathy disregard for
others and narcissism thrived
her callousness was praised her
impulsitivity was considered charming
and a notable lack of guilt was an asset
Xander had finally found a place in the
world working for the future leader of
the true Sons
during the events of the Barton Shafer
Manhunt Xander like many other true Sons
blank Schaefer for the loss of dusk
if I ever see you again I will [__]
kill you Schaefer that's a promise I
understand why you're angry but we need
to put a pin in this and focus on our
common enemy agent Lau I [__] hate
that chick I don't trust her she's been
on my list for a while not Lau she's not
the enemy she turned you into her [__]
boy you should hate her she has her
reasons
this channel is not secure but you
should really talk to Lau [__] that I'm
not letting her get into my head
shaver has been discussing what's
happening behind the scenes with Faye
for a while now and he appears to be on
board he now seems to be trying to reach
out to others to help in this fight
against the true enemy
the xender's stubbornness will require a
different approach
[Music]
what do you want Douglas
just a friendly chat this about your
girlfriend oh wow is that what this is
about you hate loud because you think
we're together no I hate Lao because
that [__] got half of my squad killed
in New York when the reservists were
called up to maintain the quarantine oh
well good
I'd hate to think you were so pissed
about how things ended with us doesn't
help that you're sleeping with a traitor
okay she's not a traitor she's a good
woman she's been through a lot we all
have
just give her a chance meet with her and
you'll see we can help each other
there's something bigger happening
to getting married would it matter if we
were
Danny Douglas you need me to go rescue
your Pappy from the White House you're
gonna finally reconcile so he can walk
you down the aisle is that the secret
mission Xander Focus we need to work
together if we're going to stop what's
coming okay fine
set it up
I'll meet with Lao
Bridget Douglas AKA Viper would later be
a part of feylau's team in the following
Manhunt
Viper was the only child of Charles
Douglas the co-founder of the Douglas
and Harding military equipment company
though they weren't particularly close
and after the outbreak Charles now
resides in the White House acting as the
range officer
Viper was an unactivated shd agent who
instead ended up joining the Black Tusk
where she would later meet agent Lau
Xander and Viper having previously been
in a relationship opened up
communications between Faye Schaefer and
the true Sons where they appear to be
recruiting for a future operation
as a side note I really must bring up
the relationship between Faye and Viper
although this isn't of any particular
significance towards the story other
than linking all of these characters
together it's more that I've been
getting a hard time at home from my wife
because she absolutely called it way
back when the feylau Manhunt was going
on but I uh I didn't agree or included
in the video I need to remember the wife
is always right so uh yeah my bad
regardless this recruiting attempt would
end up being unsuccessful Xander would
inform General Anderson who would then
get in contact with Natalia circleova
but as we now know fans out there
working under her own agenda so Natalia
has no idea what he's talking about
who wish to work with us and our fragile
truth is broken I do wish you would
reconsider my kind offer and I wish you
would reconsider trying to recruit my
men to whatever clandestine [__] you
and Lauer cooking up I don't have any
idea what you're talking about oh don't
play dumb it's not convincing on you if
Halal is reaching out to your true Sons
it is not on my orders that's on her own
volition or maybe it's your true sons
that are reaching out to her my troops
are loyal who did she allegedly reach
out to Major sander oh
well this is probably a personal matter
more than professional have you seen the
state of the world no one has time for
personal matters well women like Amanda
find a way to make the time
you don't have to worry no one is trying
to take her from you
she frankly would not be a good fit for
the Black Tusk even if she wasn't trying
to cast herself as the victim of a love
triangle just stay away from my troops
certainly General have a good day and
don't hesitate to call again if you need
anything
good luck managing Xander Douglas says
she can be a bit unstable
a little while later after Barton Chef
was captured by the division and feylau
was killed at Camp White Oak major
Xander was sent into Washington DC with
a team of true Sons
however after reports of her harsh
treatment of local civilians started
flooding in the division was sent out to
put a stop to her plans
on the Eastern side of DC they would
catch up with Xander in the Judiciary
Square District
after taking out a number of outposts
being held by the true Sons agents would
find her hunkered down in the district
Union Arena and while they would have
loved to be able to find out what Xander
was searching for there was no chance
that she would allow herself to be taken
alive
so piece by piece her true Sun soldiers
would be taken apart and in a final
stand she too would be quickly taken
down by the agents
Frederick Lewis spent many a summer on
the ocean rescuing inexperienced
tourists who'd got themselves into
trouble off the North Carolina
coastlines unforgiving Seas
with the help of his father's small
fishing boat and the fact that he had
spent the majority of his life on the
ocean Lewis was the perfect man for the
job
he had always seen himself as a savior
and the best person to bring back those
missing at Sea to their loved ones
so unsurprisingly at the completion of
high school he joined the Coast Guard
and over the course of time worked his
way up into the prestigious search and
rescue team
eventually Lewis married and at the
request of his new wife they moved to a
homestead in Kentucky
with the property value of the old
fishing shack ballooning they were able
to buy a larger state which consisted of
40 acres
yet soon after Lewis grew tired of
playing the part of a farmer and decided
to join the National Guard in the hopes
of once again finding his true purpose
though after all of his sacrifices for
his wife's happiness and moving away
from the sea he loved so much and
attempting to live a less thrilling life
for the betterment of their relationship
she was the one who started looking
elsewhere
the young man they hired to help around
the farm was the perfect candidate and
two years after their big move to
Kentucky she had an affair
when Lewis discovered the relationship
he was devastated
after everything he'd given up he still
wasn't enough for her
so he quietly picked up his bags
collected his faithful dog got into his
truck and left
Lewis knew there was only one place he
truly felt whole the ocean
his father in the sea welcomed him back
with love and open arms
once there he rejoined the Coast Guard
and tried to rebuild his shattered soul
eat his efforts would soon be undermined
again as not long after his return to
North Carolina the green poison was
released
sent to DC to help support the jtf the
impact of his experiences including his
failed marriage led him to be cold nasty
and unmerciful to those he was entrusted
to lead and protect
Captain Lewis
we ready for homecoming just a few
things to take care of here and I'll be
on my way Advanced team is already on
location
botanics hangs delivered we have more
than enough supplies for the party
that's great news when major Castillo
got to DC he recorded some very
emotional reports we decided to make
some of them public no greater
recruiting tool than a civilian who
found Purpose with the true Sons careful
Captain you keep delivering work this
good I might think you're after my job
not to worry General I hate the office
politics working with the team that's
where I belong making sure the trains
run smoothly and we all come back safe
that's where I know it can be of service
leadership support roles and
infrastructure that's the work that
fuels me we need people like you Captain
that's the thing about the division a
bunch of Lone wolves with no real
infrastructure and alliances they were
set up to fail
hire a bunch of Specialists train them
to use another to solve their problems
this is what you get
you can't depend on someone and build
trust if you only talk to them when you
need something people like that are
willing to acknowledge their
shortcomings or ask for help until
they're already in trouble this is why I
knew following you and Ridgeway was the
right call he was proactive he was
willing to make the tough calls because
he saw where the road was heading
and now that he's gone we will finish
the journey together and bring our cause
to every state in the nation good luck
in D.C
Captain Lewis chickson Regional Anderson
to give him an update on how his team
has been going in DC
everything is running according to plan
and he's ready to enact his part of the
operation
but one thing is for certain neither of
them hold the division in particularly
high regards referring to them is a
failed initiative flawed from its
Inception
we are getting ready to take the network
but there have been some unexpected
roadblocks
increased instability in the power grid
surges and blackouts some data anomalies
insecure calms and increased Brute Force
attacks
some of my men are reporting that they
have seen some odd lights and feel like
they are being watched I thought the
stress is getting to them but the
reports are coming from all times a day
and from folks I trust
major Xander is looking into it but I
don't know that her methods will yield
the results we're looking for
once in DC unusual reports start
flooding in Xander was set forth in
order to find out what's going on but
Lewis doesn't expect her direct approach
will provide the results they need
however this doesn't matter for now the
target they've been hunting for has been
found
Captain Lewis and his men sit course and
hid there immediately
Louis what's your ETA should be arriving
at the party by Sundown tomorrow
negative I need you there now we've got
a location there's some movement looks
like they are getting ready for an
extraction we need to head them off the
pass permission to take main roads and
make a loud entrance permission granted
this will put us on the division's radar
it was inevitable maybe this time
they'll actually see what we've been up
against I hope you're right frankly if
they haven't figured out what's going on
by now I don't think they ever will lone
wolves they have no trust and no support
network you pull one pin and the entire
communication chain breaks down this is
why we have contingencies
some of the coordinates I'll get my team
there ASAP
the division caught up with Captain
Lewis at the Jefferson Trade Center
but before the agents could enter Lewis
puts out a message of the comms
Etter we need backup Lewis this is Kelso
put down your weapons and surrender the
division will take care of the Black
Tusk cut the black task should be
worried about have your team meet me
inside I don't trust this guy don't
shoot him
I want to know what he's up to
Lewis is the last member left of his
team and he warns that it isn't the
black task that are the problem that
there is something worse Within These
Walls someone who refers to as the
recruiter
finally what's your status armed and
ready but the Lone Survivor of my team
if you want us to help you we need you
to secure the shade node you don't trust
me to have your back I don't trust you
around my front
that trust has to be earned Captain
defend the node we can take care of
Black Tusk watch out for the recruiter a
what oh you'll see trust has to be
earned
got something
well Kelso doesn't trust him for now the
agents at Lewis will be teaming up
against this new threat
unknown Network Detective
what the [__] I lost you for a second I
thought maybe the captain took up the
note right
oh
enemy cons revealed that Jack Bonnie is
the one leading this operation and that
this is some sort of test for him
are you ready yes tell Barney to stop
checking up on me I know what I'm doing
you know this is a test right it's his
test not mine I'm not looking for a
promotion that's why I'm checking up on
you
oh
the agents catch up with Lewis outside
of the shd node where he has secured the
area stopping the Black Tusk from once
again taking down the shd network
agent Kelso the two sons have secured
the entrance to the shade node your
comms are secure
thank you Captain
no problem agent true Sons know how to
follow orders
all right
I'm set up
agents on approach
sir get ready to be impressed
agent I've got you covered Captain what
are you doing the rest of the facility
is secure I'm providing air support we
can't let Bonnie get away what do you
mean air support hey agent unless you
need a powder shower might work in your
ass what the [__] is wrong with you
agent I don't want you breathing that
[__] friendly fire my ass
bro Striker drone
you're not the only one with air support
system
after fighting through the hordes of
Black Tusk troops the agents would
eventually meet up with Bonnie in the
final Courtyard
although he had brought along a
marauder-class quadcopter the agents
would slowly take it down
and with The Unwanted help of Captain
Lewis's dc-62 airstrikes Bonnie 2 would
be eliminated
[Music]
yeah
identification confirm agent Jack Bonnet
status classified deceased
he was an agent
classified bring me his watch I've never
seen that status before
what the [__] is going on here captain
you know nothing Kelso so not friends if
you've finally figured out what the hell
we're really up against you know where
to find me knock it off with the yellow
powder or next time I'll have to kill
you myself talk to your boy you're gonna
need our help my boy who the [__] is my
boy
I've got a weird one for you after
you're running with Captain Lewis Fred
reached out to me to Parlay we were in
the same unit before Ridgeway defected
apparently General Anderson has had a
change of heart since Jefferson Trade
Center he's realized he's no match for
the division or the Black Tusk and is
now trying to build an alliance with
their leader Natalia Sokolova she's
sending an advanced team to work at the
logistics
Matthias trig Schneider used to be a
professor and consultant for DARPA
before he was recruited by the Black
Tusk he's been working on Alternative
Energy solutions for their operations
Sean micro Clark a former Army mechanic
charged with maintaining and
retrofitting the black test combat
infrastructure if you've ever faced one
of their drones you have Micro to thank
for that
Sandra chirpy Patterson chirpy was a
sniper before Black Tusk recruited her
Shoppers shot she's racked up more kills
in the Army in DC than any other Soldier
trippy is judicious with a brass who
rarely lets a Target get eyes on her
before she takes the shot
Mitchell lucky Woods I work with some
Sailors from his Squadron they said as
soon as they docked at Annapolis he
walked off the deck and onto a Black
Tusk hovercraft I guess those rumors
about how he got promoted to Admiral
were true
and last but not least General Anderson
the new leader of the true Sons Anderson
is reportedly coming out of his hidey
hole to finalize the negotiations and is
headed to D.C this is our one chance to
take him down
agent
good luck
trick was born and raised in Copenhagen
Denmark from early on he was seen as a
gifted child with a particular interest
in mathematics at the age of 12 he moved
to the United States to study at MIT
18 he graduated with a masters in
electrical engineering and would become
the Department's youngest associate
professor his theoretical work on
perpetual energy turbines eventually
caught the eye of the defense department
and he would be brought in to consult
with Dapper scientists on several
classified projects
but it wasn't long before his skills
were noticed by others
trick would be head hunted and recruited
by the black task private military
company to find alternative solutions
for powering their hovercrafts during
off-grid and prolonged deployment
operations
for the first time we've now been given
a visual of General Anderson what is
interesting to notice is that he is
wearing General Anton ridgeway's jacket
highly to his personality and intentions
the first moment he had he grabbed
rejoy's jacket as a symbolic gesture to
assume the mantle of control over the
true Sons
others would have proven their Worth or
would have been the obvious choice as
his successor but Anderson obviously
thought he needed this as further
evidence to support his claim
regardless Anderson has now decided that
the true Sons can no longer continue
with their plans not without the support
of others
the division in the Black Tusk have
proven that the true sons are no match
so Anderson reached out to Natalia to
work out an alliance
however given our last interactions with
him Captain Lewis is likely to have some
issues with this
Lewis assisted Us in taking down one of
Natalia's operatives after his team was
taken out at the Jefferson Trade Center
but for now laws takes his orders and
meets up with one of the black task
operatives who were assessing the true
sun's position
what's your favorite geometric shape I
don't know
triangle interesting practical steady
strong stable
one of the hardest shapes to break
a shape can tell you a lot about a
person huh
it's yours technically it's a playing
curve but there's nothing more beautiful
than a parabola you see a lot of
parabolas in your line of work every
time I take a shot you don't think it's
weird that we were shooting at each
other last week and now we're supposed
to be best buddies I think it's weird
the true Sons thought they could stop us
better to get on board than get run over
exactly you really are a triangle
division agents receive and tell that
trig is located somewhere in Southwest
Washington DC
after taking out a number of freshly
acquired outposts held by the Black Tusk
they would discover that Trigg had been
hunkered down in the Jefferson Plaza
the blacktusk presence was heavy and
they had well fortified the area but the
agents were able to slowly Advance
through the facility until they
eventually met up with the target face
to face
Craig was prepared to have more than
just a gunfight as he had explosive
devices strapped all over his armor
however these certainly didn't work in
his favor before he had a chance to use
them a few quick bursts from the agents
would cause them to detonate stripping
him off his armor leaving him open to
the final kill shot
as part of her assessment of the true
Sons Natalia questions the Loyalty of
one of Anderson's most trusted
lieutenants
I'm worried about your man Lewis
he's a pencil Pusher nothing to worry
about he allied with the division during
Bonnie's test
momentary lapse of judgment
why are you protecting him he's loyal he
knows where all the bodies are buried he
won't be a problem if you're wrong about
where his loyalties lie at least he can
tell you where to bury his body
but Anderson won't have a bar of it
Lewis is one of the good ones someone
who's been there from the very beginning
someone he trusts
he would need more than a little
speculation in order to act on such an
idea
and that's exactly what Natalia would
bring
you're right those are my choices and I
have to live with them
not too late to make different choices
what the hell are you talking about can
we meet
Lewis may be a problem I'm glad you
agree
you want me to uh take care of it not
yet
watch him and see what he does next
who better to lead you to the Rat's Nest
than a rat
it would seem that whatever side Lewis
is playing for his options are now
becoming pretty Limited
as someone who's extremely loyal to the
true Sons they have now taken a turn
under Anderson's leadership to team up
with the regime that Lewis doesn't agree
with
so at this stage it would appear that
the Jefferson Trade Center mission where
he teamed up with the division won't be
a one-off
I imagine the division will be involved
in rescuing him in a future Mission
fully bringing him over to our side
potentially with other true sons that
are loyal to him he can't be the only
one who's unhappy with the direction
that the new leader is taking them
on his 18th birthday Sean micro Clark
enlisted in the Army after basic
training he was deployed into
Afghanistan growing up micro was always
very mechanically minded he loved
figuring out how things worked by
pulling them apart and then putting them
back together
in the Army he would rise to the rank of
Sergeant as a mechanic but it wasn't
long before he would have to take a
leave of absence so that he could take
care of his mother who had been
diagnosed with cancer
and his mother were very close and he
would do whatever was needed in order to
help her get better
unfortunately the medical bills were
just becoming too much to manage
he would need to find a new line of work
something that would pay enough to cover
the mounting bills and support his
family
Jack Bonnie would go on to recruit micro
into the Black Tusk as someone with a
strong set of Ethics this was a
challenging decision for micro but given
the position his family was in he set
his morals aside in order to help his
family survive
now for a quick word from this video's
sponsor me you may have heard me mention
once or twice that I recently started
another Channel now I'll be upfront and
honest and say that this is not
specifically a gaming related Channel
over the years I've had a lot of people
ask for help around starting their own
YouTube journey and while social media
influencing certainly isn't something
that interests me creating videos is
so I've created the space as a place to
point people towards when they approach
me as somewhere to help them get started
as you can see there isn't a huge amount
of content up yet as I'm just uploading
when I have the time between my other
two channels but check it out if this
interests you or if you'd like to show
some support I'd very much appreciate
any subs and likes on the videos to help
get the channel off the ground there
should be a link up in the top right
corner now but otherwise let's get back
to the video
batteries Vic I gave you enough for six
months you don't need more batteries you
just need to charge them and how do you
suppose I do that Vic use one of the
solar relays plug into the local grids
put up a wind turbine pick your poison
that takes time
Vic we don't have time
tell you what I'll give you all your
dead batteries and you can charge them
while I blow up that hostile encampment
to make sure you're safe by hostile
encampment you mean that Village By The
River a village armed with assault
rifles Vic they're not a threat I still
got a job to do and all I see is armed
threat make yourself useful
fix my batteries
you may remember this name from very
early on when we were helping the
theater settlement get up and running
the batteries powering their
Communication System were beginning to
fail agents were sent to odia tech
office declare at the high end is
holding the complex to see what they
could find they may be able to help them
[Music]
keep your head down Twisted Malik we'll
take care of this
[Music]
foreign
I can't say the same for my own efforts
thank you
the hyenas have been keeping me here to
repair their gear
if you were hoping to find anything
useful here you're out of luck
the battery packs we came looking for
already here but hey you rescued a
civilian and that's a victory and who
knows maybe Mal could be able to help us
out somewhere down the line let's call
this one agent move out
after rescuing Vikram he offers to
assist the agents with locating some new
battery packs they agreed to meet up
with them at the odia retail store
the basement beneath this store contains
the battery packs you need as well as
the only computer in DC that can still
connect to the odia network I need to
access data on that computer
get me there and the batteries are yours
my key card no longer works
but I'm guessing you can bypass this law
[Music]
foreign
the battery packs are in the basement
below us head down there now and we can
both get what we came for
system Purge started
files deleted
[Music]
to investigate
sorry to leave you like this but I can't
take the chance of those [__]
catching me again
best of luck agent
I think you're gonna need it
I see a group of hyenas heading into the
odea store
the bastard milk screwed us
at least you got one of those battery
packs but getting it out of there isn't
gonna be easy
[__]
ing mine
some for me
[Music]
[__]
whatever he was trying to hide he was
willing to kill you to keep it a secret
but you survived you got one of those
battery packs we'll send a team to pick
up the remaining stock with any luck the
theater's communication problems will be
a thing of the past as for Malik I'm
guessing he'll keep his head down for a
while
so basically the agents rescued the
crown he offered in a way to thank them
by helping them find the batteries they
were looking for
but instead it's a setup the agents are
ambushed by hyenas after he sets off an
alarm while he escapes leaving them
there to die and up until now we've
heard nothing about him since however it
doesn't sound like he's been having a
particularly good time he appears to
have been picked up by the Black Tusk at
some point and they're using him to keep
their equipment powered
unfortunately for Vikram the black tasks
have now realized how much of a pain he
is and have reevaluated his importance
to them based on how useful he really is
to their cause
is it a problem or are you concerned
that he might be a problem concern what
did he do now I think he's holding out
on us there's nothing left to hold out
Vic has served his purpose maybe it's
time to let him go though we need him to
charge the warhounds Vic was always a
temporary solution to an immediate
problem
I'm working on something more
permanent what do you want me to do with
him whatever you think is right
I thought you said you were out of
batteries no I said I gave you enough
for six months I never said I was out of
anything you're an [__] I know well
now I really don't know what to do with
you what is that supposed to mean I mean
the boss lady told me I could do
whatever I wanted with you
cut you loose kill you put you back to
work
I was gonna kill you but now I'm not so
sure that's great hey you've done a lot
for this organization
and I know we wouldn't have been able to
get this far without you so part of me
feels like you've done your service and
should be rewarded for that and the
other part thinks you just like [__]
with me and making my day harder
so that makes me want to kill you you're
not alone
plenty of people want to kill me
I'm still here yeah
I don't think that means what you think
it does Vic
having a lot of people wanting you dead
ain't some kind of badge of honor
it means you're an [__] oh I'm aware
micro see now the way you just said my
name like that
makes me want to kill you again
but you're defenseless unarmed nerd who
sells batteries
man it wouldn't be a fair fight
doesn't even seem right well since I'm
so defenseless and the world is so
brutal now
why don't you just leave me at the next
port and we'll see what kills me first
starvation
wild animals or
my many enemies
it's not a bad plan
sounds fair
sounds right
yeah
I think she'll like that outcome
division agents receive Intel that micro
is located somewhere in federal triangle
Washington DC micros forces could be
found causing chaos all over the
district public executions controlling
territories the kidnapping of civilians
and setting up outposts and strategic
areas
while sweeping through and clearing out
all the Black Tusk soldiers they come
across the division agents would
eventually discover micro's location the
Viewpoint Museum
the compound was filled to the brim with
countless numbers of drones warhounds
and mini tanks in hindsight the agents
could have made things much easier for
themselves if they'd just use EMP skills
I mean all the hints were there
beforehand but regardless they managed
to fight through
micro had backed himself into a corner
and with their Superior training and
Equipment it wasn't long before the
agents had eliminated him and his
personal guard
this seems to be the season of targets
with Annoying voices so far with trench
and now micro speaking of which I'd love
to know the story behind his nickname
the Chrome may have been snatched up by
the Black Tusk long before the agents
rescued him or maybe in between the two
side missions but I actually don't think
this was the case he doesn't seem to
heavy any allegiance to anyone but
himself
as many told us before we found him in
the retail store he was dismissed from
his role at odia a few days before the
outbreak first hit he seems to have some
other agenda and not just the deleting
of all odia files that he blatantly did
in front of us something else something
worth trying to kill the agents over
I'm not sure what it is but I get the
feeling we'll be finding out soon it
would appear that micro released him
into the wild if I was a betting man I
would say that the division will be
picking him up very soon and if that's
the case I hope we're given the
opportunity to you know slap him around
a bit because God he's a dick
to the untrained eye Sandra Patterson
comes across as Meek dainty and beakable
like a small delicate bird who in one
swift move could be broken and easily
discarded yet beneath the surface lies a
cold calculated in Psychopathic Hunter
with a brutality and disregard of life
that has awarded her with the honorable
title of the highest kill count of any
Black Tusk member a deadly sniper she is
an expert in field craft navigation and
stealth she is intelligent and extremely
patient which makes for a dangerous
combination when paired with her
outstanding abilities and Marksmanship
known for preferring to actively hunt
her targets at night comfortably perched
in the vegetation high above her
unsuspecting prey or deep in the shadows
of a bush she is roosting in her element
ready to pounce
soon the nickname chirpy was bestowed
upon her rumored to be seated by the way
in which her victims never saw her
coming and were only alerted to her
presence when it was already too late
the chirps sound admitted as the lead
bullet took flight through the silencer
was the last conscious awareness that
her victims retained before they were
permanently eliminated
at the initial outbreak of the green
poison she was already on active duty
with the Army and with the impressive
body count that chippy had already
racked up she was obviously considered a
highly valuable asset to a company like
the Black Tusk and so unsurprisingly was
nested into the organization soon after
I wonder if chirpy games and how she
deals with fatigue at the end of the day
I mean do you ever find that after a
hard day of physical work in the mines
or construction industry or something
that you can barely lift your arms and
even the weight of the mouse is too much
to take on severely hindering your
gaming time
well me either but I don't exactly have
the manliest of jobs I sit in an office
all day the most strenuous thing I do is
probably the walk from my car to my desk
but I still get tired especially if I
don't get my afternoon nap
well Logitech has taken the iconic g502
and managed to reduce its weight to an
impressive 89 grams in the new g502 X
Plus but this isn't the only upgrade
the g502 has been my go-to mouse for the
last several years for me and my giant
mouse destroying hands this sturdy Beast
has been one of the few around that has
managed to survive past the first few
months of use so when they told me about
the 502x plus I was pretty excited to
try it out straight away I noticed the
reduced latency due to the light Force
hybrid switches and an updated light
speed protocol this was actually more
obvious than I was expecting
I'll admit it felt a little odd when I
first took it out of the box as this
mouse is just so damn light but once it
started gaming I very quickly forgot
about this and actually really noticed
the advantage of list drag especially
with the hero 25k Advanced sensor
delivering the performance power and
precision we've all come to expect with
the Logitech G range
and the new LED band I've always said if
you don't have enough LED lights
streaming out through the window to
light up the driveway enough to land a
plane you're doing it wrong anyway a big
thank you to Logitech for sponsoring the
video
leading on from previous targets of this
Manhunt General Anderson is attempting
to migrate the true Sons towards the
Black Tusk and now he is beginning to
see the repercussions of this
I need your help Natalia already you
were right about Lewis he's not acting
alone and I'm worried we might have a
mutiny on our hands how many defectors
so far uh 10 maybe 20. be patient
he's turning my men against me if they
are so easily turned they were never
your men what do you suggest I do be
patient
keep watch can you help me watch him of
course
this isn't exactly a good look for
Anderson for affection that is
attempting to sell their case for why
the black tasks should trust and take
them on board this only makes them look
weak as well as raising the question of
whether he is suitable as a leader
Natalia and Anderson are now more than
aware of where Captain Lewis has perched
but before acting on it Anderson
questions Lewis directly in an attempt
to see where his loyalties lie
into the cause I'd never been more
committed to the cause sir I hear things
have been tense between you and trig I
wouldn't say tense I just personally
don't care for the man what did he do to
offend you Captain you didn't really do
anything
he called me a triangle
that was weird but I wouldn't call it
offensive
he's just odd and makes me uncomfortable
you seem to be uncomfortable a lot
lately
I don't really understand why we were
working with the Black Tusk yesterday we
were killing each other and today I'm
supposed to trust trig to have my back
do you trust me
of course then don't worry about the why
just get the job done
Black Tusk whatever they need to secure
this Alliance copy that
unsatisfied with Lewis's response
Anderson Exon Black Tusk operative
should be asking her to do what is
required to remove Lewis from the
equation and find out who else is
involved
Kirby
what do you mean I mean I could bring
him in and he could know he's being
brought in or I could just bring him in
and he will have no idea we are on to
him
handle but not control yeah sure
maybe we can uncover some more rats
exactly thank you chirpy no problem
General yeah out of curiosity why do
they call you chirpy
Jesus Christ uh thank you I understand
why they call you chirpy
but before this could happen it was one
not so small problem coming her way
shd agents would find out that chirpi
was active in downtown East Washington
DC
chopy's gaggle of Black Tusk forces have
taken a large number of strategic
locations across the district agents
waste little time in fighting through
the hordes of black dust soldiers
breaking the Outpost down one by one
eventually they would learn of chiropi's
location around Washington hotel
the Black Tusk had well establish
themselves in this facility evidence of
their occupation can be found all over
the site
and classic black tough style there were
warhounds and midi tanks fouling every
turn but the agents were able to fight
through and would eventually find chirpy
in the ballroom surrounded by guards
while her deadly pinpoint accuracy and
super annoying drone proved unpleasant
and a right burden she was the very
definition of glass Cannon and after a
lot of attempts once focused she would
quickly be taken down
this target leads a fairly linear Story
Only reinforcing what has been suspected
with Captain Lewis and General Anderson
up until now
Lewis has all but announced his future
with the true Sons under the leadership
of Anderson
the decision to join with the Black Tusk
is sent Lewis to question the direction
of this once proud faction would this
target literally been asked to sort
Louis out I expect in the next Target or
the main target to show Lewis either
escaping the group or being taken into
custody but we shall find out soon
I don't know if I did something wrong
but there didn't seem to be any
additions to the many Lewis comms in
this Manhunt Target so maybe we'll be
seeing a little more in the next or
maybe I just need to nail gun Kelso to
the basement floor the next time I see
her so I can get the new Intel
anyway because I'm a dead and I hold on
to my god-given right and societal
expectation to use dad jokes and puns I
have used exactly 25 boot-related words
in this video some more obvious than
others
Frederick Lewis grew up in the ocean
when old enough he joined the North
Carolina coast guard and over the course
of time worked his way up to the
prestigious search and rescue team after
getting married he and his wife would
move Inland where he would run a farm
due to the need for a little more
excitement in his life Lewis joined the
National Guard but when his marriage
eventually ended he wasted no time in
moving back to North Carolina and
rejoining the Coast Guard
unfortunately not long after returning
the green poison was released
when the Joint Task Force was
established his Coast Guard unit would
be sent to New York to help the jtf in
DC Lewis would be placed under Colonel
Antoine ridgeway's command and when
Ridgeway stopped taking orders from
above and started taking matters into
his own hands Lewis was one of the
soldiers loyal to his cause who would
free him from the jtf prison then
becoming the true Sons
after ridgeway's death General Anderson
would take the reins Lewis would
continue with his loyalties towards the
true Sons
Anderson would eventually have Lewis
carry out an operation in DC they were
hunting for something and they have now
found it
Lewis and his men head to the Jefferson
Trade Center immediately
this is where the division catch up with
them except he's all alone the last
member of his team
Lewis and the division team up to take
down the black task who have taken hold
of the site but while in there they
learn of an individual called the
recruiter the Target that Lewis and
Anderson seem to have been hunting
once the Black Tusk threat had been
removed and the recruiter had vanished
Lewis and the division parted ways
not long after this operation we would
find out that many and Lewis have been
communicating
Manny what do you want Captain
used to be friends that was before you
joined Ridgeway
I thought I knew you Fred you do know me
don't be like that you killed people
This Is War Manny we've all killed
people it's not the same you know that
whatever helps you sleep at night
what do you want Fred to help surrender
into custody and we've got a nice cell
ready with your name on it I said I want
to help being in jail doesn't help you
not having to wonder anymore if one of
my agents is going to punch your clock
that helps me access helps you Manny and
I've got access
Manny and Lewis worked alongside each
other in the jtf all the way up until
the day that Colonel Antoine Ridgeway
turned his back on the government after
losing faith in their ability to do what
was needed to make it through the
pandemic
the jtf around Ridgeway were faced with
a choice
to fall back to the other jtf units or
to join this new band calling themselves
the true Sons becoming an enemy of the
country
many felt back keeping to his oath while
Lewis sided with Ridgeway agreeing that
things needed to be done differently if
the country was going to survive
many and Lewis weren't just colleagues
they were friends so many took this
betrayal pretty hard
how could Sony trusted so deeply make
such a bad judgment call the jtf is the
combined forces of all the remaining
police officers firefighters Army
National Guardsmen and other civil and
military branches they are the good guys
what is he doing joining up for the
group that is essentially the enemy
working against them
but Lewis still feels that what he did
was justified however under Anderson
things have now changed
he wants to help put a stop to Anderson
and Natalia's plans
however many is going to need a little
more than just words to be convinced
that Lewis is suddenly now interested in
helping the right side
[Music]
you want an invitation to the White
House no pretty sure that would blow my
cover for all I know you're doing recon
for Anderson and this is a trap that's
why I wanted to meet so I can stare into
your eyes and know you're telling the
truth something like that where do you
want to meet
many are still very skeptical but Lewis
assures them that if they meet face to
face he'll be able to help them
understand that he really just wants to
help
you actually came alone need to build
trust
have to actually keep your word right
you didn't come along did you no but for
good reason
the Intel I wanted to share with you is
Wally nice to meet you Manny apparently
a person is Intel now we've met we have
yeah DC protest crowd control back in
December oh [__] that's right
how's your uncle dead how's your sister
dead how's my dog fine
ransom's running around here somewhere
well that's something at least what
Intel do you have Wally we've been
maintaining a power plant in Fairview
yeah a bunch of the engineers we want to
defect
Anderson is making Promises to the Black
Tusk we don't want any part of what he's
planning
many and Lewis meet up in person but
Lewis hasn't come alone he brings
someone called Wally who appears to be
an engineer at the Fairview power plant
and like Lewis she wants nothing to do
with what Anderson is planning
interestingly enough Manny knows her too
so she must have been a part of the jtf
as well
so I guess the big question here is what
is Anderson planning and how does this
involve the power plant
not much has been said on Wally just yet
but I get the feeling we'll be hearing
more about this character soon
how many more 100 maybe 120 there's too
many Fred Anderson is going to suspect
something's up he's too busy trying to
impress Natalya he doesn't know his ass
from his elbow I don't have an extra 100
beds Fred we're not ready to move yet
anyway but get ready when we pull the
trigger you're gonna have a new Army at
your disposal that's what I'm afraid of
what are you afraid of that your Army's
going to show up and my agent is going
to shoot first and ask questions later
we don't know who we can trust and if
Anderson gets wind of a mutiny before
you're ready that puts all of you in
danger you're too cautious and you're
too Reckless have faith
and get ready
lose proudly and excitedly announces
that he's managed to find over a hundred
true Sun soldiers who are willing to
follow him in joining up with many the
jtf and the division but he wasn't
expecting many to react in the way that
he did which is weird I thought he knew
many the most panicky character in the
division universe however in this case
many is probably right to be concerned
how can Lewis really know and trust that
many people to know that they won't let
this planned abandonment get back to
Anderson it could be due to someone
attempting to bolster their rank within
the true Sons willing to work undercover
and gather Intel or someone could just
slip up
regardless this is all moving very
quickly and many is the type to like a
very solid plan in place before acting
on anything at this stage he hasn't even
alerted the jtf in the division to what
he's been organizing with Lewis let
alone where he'll be able to house and
feed so many extra bodies
many is probably being a little over
cautious but Lewis is definitely being
Reckless
an army of 100 plus xjtf extrus Sons
will certainly come in useful as the
division agents haven't had any real
support for quite some time now but this
won't be enough to take down the Black
Tusk and the remaining true sons who
stayed loyal to Anderson so what is
their plan
will this force be tasked with taking
down Anderson in the final Manhunt and
whatever he's doing at Fairview power
plant
the only individual in a squadron to
survive on three separate occasions
after operations went deadly Mitchell
Woods ultimately gained his namesake
lucky though the rumors that he had
obtained advancements by destroying his
Rivals was ever present as he seemed to
be indifferent towards the loss of the
Fallen men he had served alongside in
the units
it was almost too convenient their
deaths and with very little rivalry
against him he naturally progressed over
time into more distinguished roles
within the Navy
the forest Squadron was summoned home in
the wake of the green poison epidemic
having spent his entire career in the
Navy he had successfully reached the
ranks of two-star Admiral and Navy SEAL
Commander yet coming home for lucky to
assist with the outbreak was unbefitting
to him why should he have to waste his
time on people and tasks far beneath his
status quo when he could be utilized and
appreciated by a far better cause and in
so many other ways
to Lucky the black tusks seem like the
superior alternative that he had been
looking for and thus he abandoned his
ship almost immediately in favor of the
Black Tusk hovercraft
as a result the rumors that had followed
him throughout his career were only
strengthened after he abandoned his post
lucky would reach out to General
Anderson regarding the hyenas
General Anderson I am pleased to inform
you that all ties between the Black Tusk
and the hyenas have now been severed we
will no longer be providing any
logistical Supply or weapons support to
the hyenas without our infrastructure
they will fall into disarray and it will
be easier for us to take back the
capital without interference thank you
lucky please tell Natalia that I'm
impressed by the black tusk's efficiency
and I look forward to collaborating with
her more in the future and the uh other
thing consider it taken care of
I'll give the order for my men to Grant
you clearance at the Docks so you can
assess our capabilities for yourself
this update would allow lucky access
into the true Sons where he could assess
their capabilities but shortly after
this interaction he would contact a
convoy called Roma one and reroute the
delivery
lucky to Roma one change of plans
reroute Mothership delivery to Fairview
I repeat reroute delivery to Fairview do
not proceed to 270. stay on 70 and await
further instructions
we've reached a deal with the rumors
they've agreed to transport the supplies
to Fairview but they've run into some
trouble in Virginia what kind of trouble
roadblock and hostile Convoy what do
they want for their trouble
they would like us to sweeten the deal
with a shipment of spice of course they
would
do you want me to handle the
negotiations
that would be very helpful lucky
I have to get ready for my meeting with
Anderson at Fairview
tell them the spice will be waiting for
them at the plant they can pick it up as
payment on delivery
so who are these roamers I initially
heard these comms and assumed that they
were just Black Tusk with a code name
but when they made the request for spice
this doesn't fit their MO
spice is the hyena drug of choice so
they're likely to be hyenas that they
are paying to run errands for them so is
lucky and Natalya lying to Anderson or
is this just some sort of final job
they're finishing out
feel like this should have some
significance but I'm not quite seeing
what it is at the stage
agents would discover lucky and his
forces in East Mall Washington sea his
Black Tusk had taken control of a number
of high-value outposts across the
district
seemingly taken by surprise the shd
agents fought through recapturing the
control points for the local sediments
Lucky's location would be revealed he
was holding out in the air and space
museum
the Black Tusk presence was heavy and
well organized agents would have to take
their time clearing wave after wave in
each room they progressed through
eventually lucky would make himself
known and slowly marched towards the
agents wielding a minigun and heavy body
armor
but like all Heavy units this armor was
just fodder for gaining quick Striker
stacks and it wouldn't be long before
the agents were able to pierce through
it and eliminate him
with the final Target now eliminated
General Anderson's location has now been
revealed he is at the Fairview power
plant
but he isn't the only one there other
than the hordes of Black Tusk Natalia
and Anderson have now acted on their
suspicions around Captain Lewis
this is Fred what's wrong they know the
true sons in Black tusker rounding up my
men taking them into custody if they try
to put up a fight the execute can you
get away no Wally she was on a supply
run good maybe she's safe what do I do
don't fight go with them we'll find you
the plant they were supposed to have a
meat at the plant we'll find you just
don't do anything stupid you know me I
do that's why I have to say it again
Fred don't do anything stupid
don't try to be a hero and not today
save it for tomorrow
surrender today so I can be a hero
tomorrow
so Lewis and his men have now been
captured
this mission is now more than just about
apprehending General Anderson
this is a rescue mission
over 80 percent of all communities in
the US rely exclusively on trucks to
deliver all of their fuel clothing
medicine and consumer goods
the Romans were some of the men and
women who hold these goods from state to
state in their large Freight vehicles
they transported materials livestock
Machinery liquids General Freight and
sometimes hazardous substances
the hours could be incredibly long and
in conditions that were often stressful
including poor weather and heavy traffic
repeatedly they were required to travel
long distances which meant spending many
a night far away from home
highly skilled in handling their large
Vehicles they also possess some basic
knowledge of the mechanics of their
trucks and how to maintain them
in the novel written by Thomas Parrott
the division recruited the Romans were
the ones identified as running the
northern routes
in addition they are now also in control
of the Cumberland Gap tunnel that
carries the US Route 25e under the
Cumberland Gap National Historical Park
the importance of this particular tunnel
is because it represents one of the only
safe ways for large vehicles to pass
through the mountains between Kentucky
Tennessee and Virginia after the green
poison outbreak
this passage passes through the
Cumberland mountains and consists of two
separate balls which carry four lanes of
traffic
until recently this tunnel was firmly in
the hands of the non-hostile faction
called freitis
but now the Romans are the ones in
charge
a rogue Army of truckers using the might
of Commerce to seize control
some people decided it was time to
become the worst possible version of
themselves when they realized the world
was ending and the rumors are some of
these people
essentially they are Smugglers and
they're aspiring to be the kings of the
areas under their control
they bring much needed supplies to
people but as soon as these same people
become reliant on them they've got them
by the throat and they hold on tight
enslavement and any other name
as long as the ones they Supply to
follow their explicit instructions to a
t they will provide them with just
enough to keep them going
and if they don't if they dare to rebel
against them they'll take what they want
anyhow anyway and destroyed everything
else
their attire consists of leather
bandanas worn Denim and Boots
similar in resemblance to a classic
motorcycle gang
the way in which the Romans Act is also
quite interesting as they tend to carry
themselves in a similar manner to the
true Sons
a lot of them have an arrogant and
exaggerated Swagger to their walk and
they love to gloat when they're
Victorious and they know they have won
they've turned the trucks into weapons
and have applied rough paneling to
better protect their vehicles
these cargo carriers have been modified
into improvised Fighting Machines with
guns mounted on them and some are even
equipped with machine gun nests and
small artillery pieces
they also carry a variety of small arms
mostly SMGs and assault rifles along
with the occasional M40 rifle
General Peter Anderson believed with
every bone in his body that he was an
exceptional being and an extraordinary
man
yet in reality this was just not the
case but oftentimes the way in which a
person of his egotistic mindset views
themselves with such high regard can
have a Monumental impact on those around
them
he sought immense value in establishing
and maintaining closeness with those in
positions of authority and control
Anderson was consumed with the idea of
procuring heist status for himself and
it's what drove him over almost anything
else and what fundamentally controlled a
lot of his actions
he proved himself countless times to
others that he was more than just a
simple paper pusher and served his
country in the Army the Army Reserves
and the National Guard
in school he surrounded himself with
charming popular individuals in order to
study how they were able to acquire that
social currency after being mercilessly
teased as a child for having a fixation
on order and proficiency
realizing that charismatic individuals
are really interested in the process he
saw an opportunity to position himself
as the man who knew where everybody was
interred and how the system functioned
allowing the leaders to project Charisma
while he maintained the true power
behind the scenes
Anderson can now use his years of
research into the narcissistic mentality
to his Advantage now that Ridgeway is no
longer with them and the true sons are
seeking guidance
Anderson will take the true Sons
Nationwide whereas ridgeway's Vision was
always limited and small
he'll establish a network Across the
Nation portray Ridgeway as a martyr and
demonize the division using his death
I'm pleased we could come to some sort
of arrangement Ms Sokolova please call
me Natalia
very well Natalia Cal speaks very highly
of your general uh Peter please very
well Peter
I'm sorry about all of that confusion at
Bonnie's test oh no I'm the one who
should apologize I had no idea our goals
were so aligned the trouble with Black
Ops you never know if you're secretly
shooting at your backup
that's true I hope we can be more candid
now that's the other trouble with Black
Ops candid is kind of outside the job
description
I understand do you not really but I
will I like a man who could admit when
he's wrong
well you should be careful you might
fall in love with me then you shouldn't
try to be funny
it doesn't suit you
you don't want any stationary basis I
find my teams are more effective as a
mobile unit we would maintain the ground
force and infrastructure and you would
run the trade routes and supply lines
exactly
think of your true Sons like the
skeleton and we are the blood we are
critical to maintaining structural
support true Sons will handle territory
control and Black Tusk Mobile support we
enhance one another's strengths to
protect from external forces who would
prey on our weaknesses they're smarter
than they thought well
thank you Natalia Peter
it's nothing
Anderson and Natalya discuss the finer
details behind their Alliance in one of
the more Awkward interactions I've heard
in a while
it's clear that Anderson is out of his
depth and that his position in this
Alliance is going to be placed heavily
under Natalia's thumb
the true Sons will be placed on guard
duty while Natalia's Black Tusk run
operations
how is Captain Lewis finding his new
accommodation
Fred is finding his quarters a bit
cramped and inhospitable but livable and
the rest of his friends
some have retired most are enjoying
similar accommodations and a few have
refused our invitation how many of the
few so far only one can be confirmed
Wally
yes Natalia Wally was on a supply run
and has eluded our patrols it's a shame
she was one of our best engineers
no matter
I'm sure she will be easily replaceable
I look forward to getting the full tour
as soon as you've cleared up your rat
problem
so the soldiers that Captain Lewis have
been preparing for the transfer over to
the division have been rounded up and
either locked away or executed
rescuing Lewis May provide the
opportunity to pull the remaining true
Sons still loyal to him out if it's not
too late
after the division had finished dealing
with Natalia's Black Tusk operatives who
were sent in to assist the true Sons
agents would discover General Anderson's
location at the pintco Fairview power
plant where he had a meeting planned
with Natalia Sokolova when the agents
arrived on site Anderson was assigned a
security detail by Natalya who would be
responsible for getting him safely to
The Docks but also stopping the agents
from rescuing Lewis
running through various challenges
including EMP Jammers that was set up in
the laboratory and Rising steam pressure
in the cooling tower agents would make
their way to the reactor there Lewis has
been locked away in the office while
btsu operatives activated a Fail-Safe
setting the building on fire after
deactivating the fire suppression system
division agents were successful in
turning on the valves and reactivating
the sprinklers rescuing Lewis in the
process but with little warning Lewis
took off in pursuit of Anderson
however Anderson had already made it to
the docks where Natalia had arrived with
hovercrafts
the agents would meet up with Lewis in
the parking lot where a helicopter was
waiting to extract them
Lewis
I'll send a team to intercept nah
negative
it's not worth the risk
there's a fleet of a blind house
finally made fun
she was
expected
thank you and your boys for the assist
I look forward to working with you now
that we're Partners to
[Music]
keep now there is the slight pickup that
the division took the plant
but I'm not concerned they've most
likely moved on to their next assignment
nothing she does is random
she raises her eyebrow at dinner
Mommy about an assassination
we'll regroup and take back what is
rightfully ours
thank you
and
my true sons are at your disposal and
ready to follow your orders excellent
let's get to work
[Music]
General Anderson and Natalia sokolova's
New Alliance has led to the true sons
being embittered into the Black Tusk
they have been helping Sokolova grow her
Fleet of hovercrafts in DC there are
concerns that this could lead to
increased mortar strike activity
division agents have been tasked with
taking down a new team formed through
this new alliance they are heavily armed
and know exactly where to attack in
order to do the maximum amount of damage
Charles chunks Crawford had a background
in the Navy as an ENT or Electronics
technician nuclear power before being
recruited by the Black Tusk
he was highly skilled at tending to
reactors on submarines and preferred
deep sea over the surface he was known
as chunks when he first entered the Navy
because of his severe seasickness he
discovered that he could handle
Subterranean life better than life on a
Surface ship and asked to be transferred
to the nukes
considered as the Navy's best and
brightest nukes are known for being a
bit eccentric with some struggling to
handle the stress and demands of the job
but chunks embraced this position and
saw himself as the ideal nuke
however beneath his seemingly harmless
nickname an impressive technical skills
looked a disturbing and unsettling
personality
chunks was known to have control issues
and an insatiable desire for power and
control over others
his sadistic Tendencies were evident in
his disregard for value of human life he
would often take pleasure in
manipulating and dominating his
subordinates treating them like mere
tools to be used for his own benefit in
his mind the ends always Justified the
means no matter how many lives were
sacrificed in the process
his Twisted Behavior made him a feared
and respected member of the Black Tusk
his superiors appreciated his unwavering
loyalty and willingness to carry out
orders without question
chunks may have been a master attending
to reactors but his true Talent Lena's
ability to manipulate and control those
around him
everything's a work in order but morale
is low main complaint
food we've got plenty of MREs but all we
got are MREs the crew is getting enough
to eat but it's not enjoyable you want
me to find you a chef that's excessive
but if we could get some fresh food it
would go a long way towards boosting
morale you want salads yes there are
plenty of wild edibles by the river or
we could just take the campus in time
for now
if you want a salad go forage one
how's morale great your team enjoying
foraging not exactly I told you to leave
the campus alone we did I don't need you
drawing unwanted attention before we're
ready we found a small community North
of the city any agent no all civilians
some kind of prepper or Homestead
community
they were isolated and well hidden not
that well hidden we spotted three of
them fishing and tracked them back to
Camp with a drone occupy or Raid
occupy left a couple of guards to keep
their operation going
we can rely on weekly Harvest from the
farm for the troops in DC and they've
already put up a fair amount for winter
do you need replacements for the guards
not yet but we could use transpo if you
want to supply the other teams
is it true is what true what people are
saying about St Louis I have no idea
what you're talking about
well it is there was an attack you're
going to have to be more specific
that's some Rogue agents working
together
what would the outcast be doing in St
Louis
you tell me you're acting paranoid do we
need to worry about radiation poisoning
from St Louis from Outcast no are you
sure yes if you're really worried get a
geiger counter where am I supposed to
get one of those Department of interior
Parks and Recreation your prepper group
a spy museum the power plant pick your
poison
[Music]
on first lesson these comps and may not
seem very significant but the last one
in particular is actually referencing
events that played out in the division
recruited novel
confirming that the game is playing out
alongside the novels and it's quite cool
to see the Crossovers here
to give some background Rowan was a
former division agent turned Rogue and
was once a part of the sale of agents
that the novel follows
Rowan's family had been killed following
the outbreak like so many others
but she was later believed that the true
Sons were responsible due to the events
that played out on Roosevelt Island
when in reality this was a lie told to
her by the cell leader
her family were sent into a quarantine
but it wasn't the jtf or the true sons
who killed them
after the outcasts took over and seized
control of the camp the division
launched a strike and her family was
caught in the crossfire and killed
the division killed a family of an agent
and that was hidden from her
she would go on to weaponize a sample of
the green poison and then release it
into the water supply of an encampment
of true Sons
the true Sons were decimated but not
before they had spread it to three
nearby civilian communities
hundreds of people died
but Rowan would then find out the truth
of what actually happened to her family
and she took the Betrayal hard
two division agents were dispatched to
bring her in for questioning
he killed both and then disappeared
erections drew the attention of the
outcasts they approved of her measures
and given that they are now leaderless
she obviously offered them something in
return for their help
the attack in St Louis happened while
the cell was in pursuit of Rowan who was
on her way to attack one of the shd
calls
there were explosions and the buildings
around them started to crumble and this
is where Isaac announced warning
radiation detected the outcasts were
using dirty bombs
now it makes sense that chunks is so
concerned about this being a former Navy
nuclear technician is more than well
aware of the dangers of radiation
I don't think the story has caught up
with what happened at the end of
recruited so I won't talk about that
anymore in this video however given
circle of his response to this there
could be more crossovers to come
regarding outcasts and I'm going to
speculate more on this in another video
soon
the story of chunks demise began with a
tip received by the division agents
according to their Intel chance was
hiding somewhere within the West Potomac
Park of Washington DC
the Agents set out to take down the
Black Tusk outposts one by one until
they found themselves at the Lincoln
Memorial
black task had fortified the area
heavily and it seemed like a daunting
task for the agents to get through but
they were determined to stop chunks and
slowly but surely they made their way
through the facility
despite facing numerous enemies
including heavily armed guards and
warhounds the agents were Relentless in
their Pursuit
finally they came face to face with
their target
chunks appeared to be caught off guard
and didn't put up much resistance
the agent swiftly cleared out his
bodyguards and in no time chunks was
eliminated
firstly let's talk about the castle
sediment
it has been years since the settlement
was first attacked by the true Sons
using a weaponized version of dc-62 but
to be fair in game it's only been a few
months
there have been rumors around the castle
sediment but I haven't paid much
attention as there wasn't anything
official to back it up
my first thoughts when we were directed
there in game there is more to the story
we don't need another settlement we've
been fine without it so far however it
does paint the picture that perhaps the
jtf and civilians are doing a little
better in DC than we've been led to
believe up until now I've always felt
the existing settlements and even the
White House were barely holding on at
this point but if they are able to
divert this much Manpower and other
resources perhaps things aren't as Grim
as they've seemed over the last few
months in game
however like I just said I believe there
is more to the settlement
when running around and checking out the
compound you can see a lot of work going
on comms being set up electricity
foundations for buildings farming spots
plus a number of jtf who look like
they're just over this [__] and probably
should have just called in sick
the underground area seems to have been
locked off but there is another way down
there heading onto the street you can
find this entranceway that leads you
directly under the settlement there are
no guards or anything but there are
doors to be opened it still works in the
same way as the settlement as in you
cannot use weapons Etc except there
really is nothing down there I've been
through it a number of times and there's
nothing except for a few unmarked
civilians
but back up in the main section you can
find a crafting table and a
recalibration station
this immediately struck me as odd as
there are only so many locations that
have this and the other two DC
settlements certainly don't
from everything I'm seeing here the area
feels incomplete not just because
they're currently rebuilding the place
but that there is far more planned for
the area in the near future
I feel like a lot of the assets here are
just placeholders for the next few
months where eventually this place will
be of far greater significance to the
story and I'll expand on this idea
further a little later in the video
[Music]
when first jumping into season 11 we
meet Manny for the usual Target brief
but then we are immediately sent to the
castle to meet Wally
there has been an increase of Hunter
drone activity in DC and she has managed
to hack into a couple of them revealing
some Intel
now this is obviously the way that the
main comms are going to be acquired this
season but it's good to hear the hunters
are still being featured in the story
anyway the first two comms we've
received through this until follows a
similar path of the Intel received in
the chunks Manhunt
got proud of DC I spoke with Cal
yesterday and he has assured me that the
rumors are just rumors the report out of
St Louis a complete fabrication nothing
to worry about
even if it were true it's an anomaly not
a trend
nothing for you to worry about what
about supplies going through the area we
have alternate routes
there is no danger of shortages if
that's what you're worried about hey you
talk to chunks I have
I assure you there are no shortages and
we have more than enough to sustain us
we are in this for the Long Haul
the first one covers something I
discussed in the chunks Manhunt video
I'll leave a link to this in the top
right but essentially Stoke pipe is
asking if these rumors are true based on
the recruited novel they are 100 True
yet for some reason Natalia or perhaps
McManus is denying it
hypothetical question okay
hypothetically
what would happen to a mortar operator
if they were to use a launcher that had
previously housed a dirty bomb
Too Many Factors to consider exposure
time amount of radioactive material
amount of transfer
what kind of particulate it wouldn't be
instantly fatal of course not
we're exposed to radiation every day by
the time you're showing symptoms of
radiation poison
it's generally too late thank you chunks
why are you asking no reason
I just like to be prepared for all
scenarios
if you're worried about exposure at the
plant you should start taking iodine to
protect your thyroid that's a very
useful information
this to me shows that Natalia doesn't
believe what McManus is saying to her
about the events in St Louis
or maybe her and McManus are just trying
to cover this up from their crew for
some reason
what's more interesting about this piece
of Intel is what chunks said at the end
there about taking iodine to help
protect the thyroid
the reason this is interesting is
because of something that Wally said
after completing the chunks Manhunt
guess we should start looking for
natural sources of iodine just in case
should probably start eating more fish
and seaweed from Mario's exhibits at the
aquarium
it took me a few seconds to click when I
first heard this to begin with I thought
this was an unknown name that would
become more important over the course of
this Manhunt as they don't tend to give
names of characters unless there is some
sort of significance to this story going
forward
but some of you may remember this name
come up in one of the classified
assignments that came out in year one
this particular one was called Central
Aquarium
you could be forgiven for forgetting
what this was all about and it certainly
had me looking through the others for a
bit of a refresher but long story short
we were there to rescue Mari Singh and a
number of other civilians at the
aquarium that was being taken over by
hyenas but the rescue wasn't really the
significant part
I'm not going to play all of the comms
as this could be a standalone video on
its own but the Intel from this
assignment showed the interaction
between Murray and her colleagues they
were short on supplies and worried about
what they were going to do going forward
when it came to feeding the animals
under their care
everything was locked down they weren't
able to get trucks in and they couldn't
simply take the animals away
they contemplated feeding the smaller
fish to the large ones in mammals but
this would only be a temporary solution
Murray eventually acknowledged that the
city is full of hungry people and that
food is running out perhaps the best
solution was to honor the animals and
provide them as food for the hungry
population rather than just let the
animals starve to death
but it wasn't just all about killing off
the larger animals and feeding them to
the people
the aquarium has a sustainable fishing
program they have the facilities to
provide a communal fishery a source of
food for the starving civilians
this was certainly a big deal at the
time a sustainable source of food but
with everything else going on in year
one it was easy to have forgotten this
however with the threat of radiation
along with the growing need for food the
mention of Murray and her fishery is no
coincidence
she and her aquarium are something that
we're gonna have to fight for going
forward
I don't usually do this but I'm going to
play the trailer and discuss what I
think could be important going forward
we got used to winning
beating our enemies
or turning them to our cause Schaefer is
still in a coma so I don't believe we'll
be seeing anything from him this season
I could be wrong here who may make an
appearance later but I don't think this
will be the case this Manhunt
[Music]
but now they have their own Alliance
led by Sokolova
and if the Mastermind of the Black Tusk
is coming to Washington
it will be to eliminate the division
that's why she needs stovepipe
they don't care about the cost this
agent Watch scene is something I pointed
out on Twitter and Instagram it shows
that there are more than just trophies
for the hunters that they are drawing
Intel from them but what they already
seem to know everything about each agent
especially given that Kelvin McManus as
the Secretary of Homeland Security has
had all of this information around the
division agents so what information are
they Gathering somewhat off topic I'm
seriously considering setting up my
recording studio like this I feel it
would really put me in the zone
only who wins and finally we have the
White House going dark
to me at least this symbolizes an attack
or at the very least the DC base of
operations is being targeted and brought
to its knees
maybe this is the end of Schaefer due to
the power supply being cut I don't think
so though or at least I hope not there
is a reason they've kept him alive in
the story for this long
but I think this could be the answer to
all of my questions around the castle
sediment
it's probably a bit of a stretch but
that's never held me back before I think
the White House is finally going to come
under attack I've been cushioning this
for quite a while
the black tusks certainly have the
overwhelming Manpower and equipment to
do this up until the castle sediment
being restored the White House appears
to have been run by a skeleton crew as
the jtf numbers have dropped so low
perhaps them sending so many people to
rebuilding the castle settlement is the
reason it's finally being attacked
I don't know but whatever happens I
think the castle is going to be our new
base of operations even if just
temporarily while recapturing the White
House
Lieutenant Martin bantam's background as
a U.S army drone operator gave him a
unique perspective on warfare
he was able to control unmanned aerial
vehicles and used them to Target enemy
combatants without ever sitting foot on
the battlefield
however as time went on Bantam would
become desensitized to the violence he
was causing from afar as he transitioned
to become a member of the true Sons
Bantam continued to use his skills to
Target enemies from a safe distance
however his beliefs about responsibility
began to morph into a twisted
justification for his actions Bantam
convinced himself that he was not
responsible for the deaths caused by his
drone strikes as long as he did not
physically see blood on his hands he was
able to ignore the fact that his actions
were causing real-life consequences for
other human beings
this cognitive disconnect allowed him to
continue his violent Behavior without
any remorse it's clear that bantam's
mindset is a dangerous one
by disconnecting himself from the
reality of the situation and the harm
he's causing he's able to justify his
violent actions and become a danger to
those around him
Lieutenant Martian Bantam is a
cautionary tale about the dangers of
Detachment and warfare and how it can
lead to dangerous beliefs and behaviors
prior to the operation Bantam expressed
his doubts about collaborating with the
Black Tusk he had always been a loyal
true son but the recent alliance with
the Black Tusk had made him uneasy he
knew that their ultimate goal was to
gain control of the capital and Rule it
with a nine fist
but he wasn't sure that their method was
something that he was able to be a part
of
[Music]
set up on the Potomac and ready to
deploy General thank you Bantam hold
tight what are we waiting for I wish I
could tell you above my pay grade or
above yours too sir it's neat to know
but do you know I know enough
are you sure about these people sir I'm
sure that if we want to win this war
Lieutenant we need allies but these
allies do you have enough food yes do
you have housing and clean clothes
yes do you have enough weapons and
medical supplies yes do you have enough
mortars enough to level the city so do
you feel like you have the tools and
resources at your disposal to win this
war absolutely how do you feel about our
new allies now better General good
hold tight and wait for orders
it was torn between his loyalty to the
true sons and the Practical benefits of
working with the Black Tusk but
ultimately he knew that the true Sons
couldn't have kept going in the way that
they were their resources were dwindling
and this situation was becoming
increasingly dire
the true Sons were in disparate need of
a game changer and this could be it
is
Castle
the castle settlement yes sir what about
the dc-62
extensive decontamination efforts have
been made since Captain Wilson's attack
looks like they're getting ready to
reopen the settlement
well good for them while he's been seen
at the castle as well makes sense they
were always close no news on the other
Target Natalia I'd like to hear that
from you do you mind giving her a call
there's nothing to tell huh she'd like
to hear it from you I'd rather not why
not
sir she scared the [__] out of me
any updates no ma'am eyes on the Target
no ma'am do we at least have
confirmation that he's still on site no
ma'am do we have anything we have
footage of him being brought back to the
White House after Coney Island he was
badly injured no aerial footage since is
he still alive no way to confirm at this
time if he's alive they they never let
him outside
bantam's aerial drones have shown what
is happening at the castle sediment and
the huge efforts going into rebuilding
it but also the movements going both in
and out of the White House
they are now very aware of Captain
Lewis's involvement with the castle
being rebuilt as well as Wally
they are also now aware that Barton
Schaefer was taken to the White House
but they have no idea if he's still
alive or not
I wonder if my suspicions are correct
about the White House coming under
attack but the potential for Schaefer to
be alive with all the secrets he holds
be the reason they attack
we want to retrofit more mortars I'm
gonna need more dc-62 thank you for
telling me Lieutenant General does that
mean you're going to send more DC 62
yeah at this point contamination threats
may not be in our best interests visible
contamination what are you implying
rumors about radiation sir oh rumors
what rumors about the plant no St Louis
what about St Louis you really don't
know do you excuse me there's nothing to
know
I can't tell if you're full of [__] or
your new friend is teaching you to be a
fantastic [__] liar watch your tone
Lieutenant I don't give a [__] about my
tone I want to know if I need to worry
about radiation poisoning sir
this Combs continues the rumors that was
started in the chunks Manhunt and while
we know that the attack on St Louis
aren't just rumors I'm beginning to
think that this isn't just a nice
crossover to the novels
this is going to feature more heavily
going forward but I really can't put my
finger on how at this point dirty bombs
radiation how would this assist either
side going forward if these were brought
to DC or New York
or maybe that's the point perhaps those
crazy bastards known as the outcasts are
going to be the reason for the Black
Tusk and the division to call the truce
for a little while but if that was the
case wise McManus Circle over and maybe
Anderson tried to hide it from everyone
[Music]
following the successful elimination of
their first Target chunks division
agents quickly received Intel on
Lieutenant Martian bantam's whereabouts
it was revealed that he was actively
operating within the Foggy Bottom
District of Washington DC which prompted
agents to launch a full-scale operation
to take down the true Sun outposts in
the area
with each Outpost that was taken down
the agents gathered more information
about bantam's location which eventually
LED them to the heavily defended
compound of the Potomac Event Center
the true Sons were abundant in Supply
and it was clear that this was going to
be a challenging mission
despite the odds the division agents
were well prepared and had the necessary
equipment to take on the heavily
Fortified Compound
the white death with its overpowered
Talent determined proved to be a game
changer and it felt more like target
practice than a national battle
as agents made their way through the
compound they eventually came face to
face with Bantam himself
in an uncharacteristic move Bantam
decided to engage in the fight himself
showing a level of Courage that was
unexpected from someone who had
previously hidden behind a screen
however his efforts were no match for
the well-trained division agents
with one swift Bullet to the face Bantam
was taken out of commission
it's unclear whether he would have put
up much of a resistance if he hadn't
engaged in the fight but the agents were
relieved to have completed their mission
successfully
the elimination of Bantam would bring
the one step closer to tracking down
their main target
stovepipe
Mort curse Kellogg's life took a turn
for the worse when he developed a
serious gambling problem he found
himself in debt to Loan Sharks before he
even graduated from high school and the
debts only grew larger as time went on
eventually he realized that he needed to
do something drastic to get out of debt
and avoid his collectors so he enlisted
in the army
he was deployed to the dagger complex in
darmstadt Germany where he quickly
became known for his logistical
expertise he had a natural talent for
managing suppliers and his superiors
took notice however cursed was never
able to shake his gambling habit even in
Germany he continued to gamble on Sports
and other events often putting himself
further into debt
when the green poison was released
Hearst was on a weekend trip to
Copenhagen in Malmo where he bought a
Euro jackpot lottery ticket
he played his lucky numbers and forgot
about the ticket and told the drawing
the following Friday to his amazement
all of his numbers came up but his
excitement was short-lived as he learned
about the viral outbreak that was
rapidly spreading across the globe
curse luck seemed to have run out but
fate had other plans
he would eventually join the Black Tusk
and become one of the highest ranking
Logistics officers
his expertise in managing supplies and
resources made him invaluable to the
organization and he quickly Rose through
the ranks
his gambling habit may have put him in
debt but it also gave him a natural
talent for taking calculated risks
something that would serve him well in
this new position
as a member of the Black Tusk Hearst was
instrumental in many of their operations
using his expertise to help the
organization acquire the resources they
needed to accomplish their goals
despite his past he had become a
respected and trusted member of the
group and his loyalty to the cause was
never in question
um you want me to reach out to Bantham
or Kaplan Kaplan Phantom seems nervous
huh a lot of these true Sons defected
they did
looks like they weren't as loyal to
Anderson as he thought
the trouble with following a charismatic
leader when you lose the leader you lose
your following agreed best part of
working for a faceless organization
you're behold to a power structure not a
narcissist
can't tell if you're being sarcastic no
sarcasm I signed on for the big picture
Safety and Security
you know me so well I do
and that's why I think you're the right
person to reach out to Kaplan we need to
weed out potential traders in our midst
you worry she's a traitor no
I think she's got the right access
psychology and skill set to spot them
Natalia is looking for any more
potential traitors within the true Sons
it believes Kaplan could be the one to
find them this Khan's piece also shows
the sort of loyalty Hearst has with
Natalya and the Black Tusk
no updates on Schaefer thank you
just wanted to confirm bantam's report
is it going to be a problem I don't
think so
he's too afraid of me to betray me I
don't know how anyone can be afraid of
you that's because you've never been on
the receiving end of my wrath cursed
that's true you have saved my life on
more than one occasion have you found
anything only thing a note I've seen
some specialized medical equipment going
in and out of the White House could be
for Schaefer could be nothing no way to
tell without infiltrating the White
House that's a suicide mission
stick to Recon for now
confirmation that someone's in a coma
but you can't confirm it is Schaefer
that's unfortunately correct Source we
apprehended one of the cooks and how
does that confirm a coma patient they
were instructed to make meals for tube
feeding and maintain feed line
sanitation but they never installed the
line or saw the patient that's correct
said that there was restricted access to
his room who has clearance
[Applause]
Kelso Dr Summers and our old friend
well he sure fell into favor quickly is
there an opportunity there perhaps
he's been turned before
men like that aren't the most loyal
[Music]
Captain Lewis has shifted loyalties
twice in the past we abandoned the jtf
true sons and then once again more
recently when he teamed up with the
division Natalia sees this as a
potential opportunity
they still haven't confirmed that
Schaefer is in there but they're
certainly getting close
it's seeming more and more likely that
if this attack on the White House does
happen that Schaefer is going to be the
reason for it Natalia knows that he has
too much Intel to give if he was to ever
wake up
are you worried about radiation
you've been talking to chunks haven't
you no stove paint just take your iodine
and calm down you don't think the rumors
are true about St Louis yeah I think
anytime people tell you a rumor is just
a rumor they're trying to cover
something up so yeah I think the rumors
are true
[__] don't worry about St Louis worry
about Fairview why
you've seen the way they handle the
nuclear waste
no no they would have told us
brother I think your helmet's on too
tight
I'm still not sure how the events in St
Louis would tie into the store yet I
don't see us hitting over there but
maybe it'll have something to do with
the future conflicts against the
outcasts
however what I find more interesting is
the reference to Fairview power plant
not just from cursed but also from Wally
right after receiving these comms
ever since we lost major Castillo that
place has gone to [__] I get why he had
to take him out that man's grief drove
him to some really dark places
when Majors Castillo was taken out there
wasn't really anyone to look after the
plant yes he trained to fuel the true
Sons to keep things running but this was
never going to be adequate in the long
term
Phantom's training is a nuke more than
justifies his concerns however he's now
gone too
Natalia is a smart lady Julie she is
aware of what's Happening Here but what
is she planning
forget dc-62 or even the green poison
radiation and dirty bombs could soon be
the problem and as far as I'm aware I
don't think the division has anyone
qualified to fix it so you can't exactly
storm the area
as the division agents received Intel on
what cursed's Kellogg's whereabouts they
quickly mobilized and headed towards
Constitution Hall where the black task
was conducting their operations the team
had to move cautiously and strategically
taking down various outposts one by one
throughout the district to ensure their
cover wasn't blown
once they cleared the outposts the
agents discovered the cursed had moved
to Tidal Basin a heavily Fortified Area
controlled by the Black Tusk
the team had their work cut out for them
but they were determined to take down
the enemy and put an end to their plans
they encountered Fierce resistance as
they made their way through the area but
their extensive training in Superior
Equipment proved to be too much
eventually cursed would make his
presence known and approach the agents
exceptionally slowly
at this point it's hard not to feel
sorry for Mort curse Kellogg not only
did he have a gambling addiction that
would eventually result in him being
placed into this very position the
agents are facing right now but he would
also be trolled by the Black Tusk who
would put him in the hilariously clunky
armor with a belt-fit minigun that the
agents were more than familiar with by
now
after clearing his Entourage the agent
spent a little bit of time playing with
their prey until they eventually decided
to show him how it was done by pulling
out their own minigun and Blasting holes
straight through his armor
foreign
cursed Kellogg status deceased
Beatrice Auntie Kaplan with a
deceptively sweet and unassuming
presence of as a dark and dangerous side
that lurks beneath the surface
mocking the conventional expectations of
society Kaplan having no desire to have
children would often joke about a future
as an eccentric old cat lady
during basic training at the first
target practice session a new recruit
playfully gave her the name Auntie
shortly after this new recruit as well
as Kaplan would be involved in what she
called a reloading accident that would
ultimately claim the recruit's life
any doubts of whether the incident was
actually an accident would be cleared up
after she shamelessly sees the
opportunity to wield her Newfound infamy
insisting that everyone a dresser is
Auntie she sought to instill a sense of
fear and respect from those around her
Auntie showed no guilt or remorse for
her actions and instead used it as a
stark reminder of the ever-present
danger and mortality that hoarded their
lives of their crosster but also to
solidify her position of power and
dominance within the ranks
when she heard news about the true Sons
aligning themselves with the Black Tusk
she was most excited about the fact that
she would no longer go by the name petty
officer Kaplan and instead have people
continue to refer to her as auntie
in awaiting orders General thank you
Kaplan Auntie right
thank you Auntie no problem General
about those orders continue to do
perimeters sweeps of all known division
control location s and look for any weak
spots or opportunities and if I find any
you want me to move in or report back
observe and report for now
Italia has a plan and we need to support
her vision
do we get to know what that vision is
eventually when the time is right we
still don't know who we can trust this
Alliance is too new and Lewis has
unfortunately brought too many people to
his side
you worried about Bantam should I be
well is he still insisting you call him
Lieutenant Phantom yes it's like
switching teams just because you put on
the uniform it doesn't make you a part
of the team and if you won't even put on
the uniform how much do you really want
to be on the new team right
good point auntie
permission to go off base why I want to
meet cursed in person permission denied
I just meet two hours we can find a
neutral place to meet why do you want to
meet him he reached out
wants me to help root out the rest of
the rats and Traders we're talking about
Bantam again no
banton's cute chicken [__] to do
anything he'll die before he grows the
balls to defy orders I don't know about
that
he's harmless
I mean unless you order him to kill
people then he's actually pretty good at
his job
but he's not one to get original ideas
and if a bad actor gets in his ear oh
well then yeah he can be easily
manipulated
you want me to keep tabs on him just in
case that might not be a bad idea
quietly remotely
don't let them know you're watching
that's the only way I know how to watch
permission denied why
worried I'll draw too much attention
need to stay on Mission worried I'll get
distracted or something who knows
I'm forward to meeting you me too
the tree you were stationed in Germany
when this all went down
it is you ever see combat before this
I've been deployed what's your number
before this
um
20 or 30
50 I stopped counting really yeah
too hard to keep track not for me what's
your number
372.
were you deployed before this
nope
went through basic and joined the guard
we never got to see any real action
until the jtf was activated
372 kills this year
that's impressive 371.
actually
these cones are just a continuation of
the conversations cursed was having with
Natalia she has asked kurz to get in
touch with Auntie and use her to help
weed out the traitors
these are all showing that Natalia
doesn't hold the true sons in
particularly high regard especially
after Captain Lewis jumped ship with a
large group of the true Sons
it also shows that Natalya continues to
have absolutely no confidence in General
Anderson he has been left completely in
the dark and now has her man going
around him in order to discuss plans
with certain true Sons
I know about the dirty bombs what about
them you're a little experiment here
someone stole it and used it in St Louis
what experiment the goddamn dirty bombs
Natalya stovepipe I have never approved
experimental dirty bombs perhaps the
isolation is getting to you
you're full of [__] Natalya I do not
appreciate your tone I don't give a [__]
get me out of here I'm done finish
setting up the base at Coney Island and
I'll send a relief team to finish your
mission in New York
we can sort out this confusion when you
get back to base
through this interaction we learn of the
location of stovepipe pony Island it
sounds like he is setting up a base for
an attack on New York City with all of
these past comms this season it appears
Natalia could be planning to use Jersey
bombs on the city obviously stovepipe
isn't particularly happy about this and
chooses to call her out and who can
blame him everything we've heard has led
us to similar suspicions
one thing is for certain though the
disrespect he's shown there is no way
Natalya will let that slide
Auntie's downfall started with a tip
that reached the division agents
revealing her presence in Washington
DC's West End district with this
information in hand the agents embarked
on a mission to dismantle the true Sun
outposts progressing through until they
eventually find out that Auntie was
located on Roosevelt Island
the island stood as a daunting challenge
for the determined agents but undeterred
by the overwhelming odds they pressed
forward navigating the treacherous
landscape of the compound
the area had been heavily fortified by
the true Sons presenting a formidable
challenge for the agents to overcome but
step by step they would push through and
eventually close them on Auntie however
in typical division agent fashion they
would shoot first and ask questions
later
they actually didn't get a visual
confirmation on the target before
one-shotting something through some
foliage
they would have to run to the other side
of the map to confirm it was her and
with this target down an all-available
Intel gathered the agents would be able
to move on to the main target stovepipe
though I hope her sister doesn't seek
revenge I don't think that fight would
go down in quite the same way
Zachary stovepipe BT possessed a unique
and dangerous fascination with
explosives that would eventually shape
his path in unexpected ways
trained as an explosive Ordnance
disposal Specialist or EOD he initially
immersed himself in the study of
demolitions out of sheer passion
while his primary Duty was to neutralize
explosive threats stovepipe Sensational
curiosity led him down a dark path
as he delved deeper into his field
stovepipe's obsession with the
destructive power of explosives grew he
meticulously collected schematics
prototypes and classified information on
increasingly unstable improvised
explosive devices
he pushed the boundaries of his
knowledge exploring the most hazardous
and volatile designs all in the pursuit
of a fascination with watching the world
burn
surprisingly stovepipe's unorthodox
collection didn't lead to the expected
consequences instead of facing a court
martial for his dangerous hobby his
commanding officer recognized the
potential value of his expertise and
connections
this recognition ultimately sparked an
unexpected turn of events when the Black
task took notice of snowpipe's unique
skills and approached him with an
intriguing proposition
the Black Tusk sorn stovepipe a person
who shared their desire to exploit chaos
for their own game
they recognized his uncanny ability to
navigate the world of destructive
technology and the potential for him to
come a valuable asset in their
operations
drawn to the Allure of power stovepipe
accepted the invitation to join the
ranks of the Black Tusk
it was within this organization that his
expertise and explosives would find its
true purpose
in position inventory assessment
complete how are we looking on mortars
even with the two new teams we have more
than enough to maintain control of the
shipping lanes that's very good
let me know if we need to pull in
additional resources we'll do but
honestly this feels like Overkill to
secure the river better to Overkill than
be killed
funny you need anything else from me not
at this time stovepipe can't you just
call me Zach wouldn't be professional
stovepipe I hate that nickname most
people hate their nicknames you didn't
make Faith take a nickname say it was
special
and what am I reliable
presumably on Coney Island Stoke pipe
updates Natalia on the status of the
setup including the Muay Thai launchers
that they'll be using to keep hold of
the river
why do you want to know that
professional curiosity no there is no
way to use dirty bombs in arm order
launchers without contaminating the
launcher that's what I thought I just
wanted confirmation I don't like this
hypothetical question it's just a
question it's a [__] up question
that's the world is this about St Louis
what do you know about St Louis
dirty bomb attack on a convoy rumors
conjecture and fear-mongering to keep
people from moving through the Midwest
are you sure letting me sort through the
propaganda you just keep digging through
that Intel and see if there's anything
we can use
you got it boss
why humor me there is no safe way to
house this [__] long term short term do
you care if people die of course
then concrete lead concrete and
lead-lined crates that no one touches
without full radioactive protection at
all times with decontamination showers
after then deconstruct destroy and bury
the launchers after use
it doesn't make sense
the risk isn't worth it unless you want
people to die of radiation poisoning
thank you stealth pipe seriously
is this about St Louis was that us it
was not us
so it's true
St Louis happened of course it happened
why did you lie to me you didn't need to
know
these cones are obviously from before
the stovepipes Outburst in the columns
that we heard while hunting down Auntie
he brings up Saint Louis twice and
Natalia even admits to lying about the
events that happened there this on top
of Natalya's questions about radiation
in dirty bombs he is right to be nervous
if this is what Natalia is planning
agents realize they need to close in on
his position and fast
when agents arrived on the island it was
quiet too quiet
in fact there were no enemies at all and
senses indicate that the stovepipe
hasn't moved since the agents arrived
eventually they would catch up to
stovepipe except someone had beat them
to it
he was already dead
it was a trap
from the Black Tusk coppercraft in the
distance a swarm of drones as well as a
couple of marauder-class quadcopters
were launched on the agent's position
agents attempt to reach the extraction
point but wave after wave of drones mini
tanks warhounds automated turrets and a
heap of emps are blocking their way
they managed to quickly push through but
before Torres was able to pick them up
there is one small enemy that needs to
be removed
but don't let the name fool you that
[__] is Satan's hellhound and
here I go a little off story and break
the immersion my wife uh Slash manager
told me I should probably remove this
part because it's a little bit off-brand
but I promised a few of you that I
wouldn't hold back on my emotions and
true feelings about this part of the
mission so the following are actual
clips of my first few playthroughs let's
just call this an intermission boy but
feel free to skip forward a minute or so
to continue the story just [__] off but
for [__] sake avocado
[Music]
second
immediate medical ah why
ah
hey hey jump on for a few minutes just
to finish off the main hunt won't take
long yeah man give me a moment why does
he keep chasing me what the [__] is
wrong with this damn thing you got this
he's actually not so bad when you're at
Big Chase bro are you dead again yeah um
yeah yeah I am
the fact that his name is Sparkles only
makes it that much worse
after the agents managed to put a stop
to the final Target on Coney Island
comfortably definitely without getting
close to rage quitting several times
Torres was about to come in and extract
them however this is when the true depth
of this situation really came to light
while the agents have been playing at
the dog park the Black Tusk have
attacked the White House
it all makes sense now stovepipe and the
whole attack on Coney Island was just a
distraction
Sokolova was waiting until the agents
were off site before taking down the
network and then attacking the White
House
the only reason they are able to
communicate and use skills now is
because of Wally's mobile shd server
fighting through the outskirts agents
make their way through the black task
forces to meet up with Kelso at the
White House
as the agents make it to the gates they
watch as several Black Tusk helicopters
depart with one of them carrying the
perfusion bioreactor
at the compound they come across a
Razorback that has been set up on the
White House lawn
after a surprisingly short encounter
given what has been experienced through
this Manhunt so far agents would make
their way through to the White House
alongside Alani Kelso
what they found was a massacre
while all of the black tasks had cleared
out from the compound the agents were
left with the Stark reality of what had
just occurred
along with many others Captain Lewis had
given his life to protect the jtf in the
base of operations
through Echoes on site the agents were
able to see that Lewis had made the
ultimate sacrifice in order to give many
the time to escape and hide with
Schaefer
while Lewis was comfortably holding his
own it would seem that one of Natalia's
Hunters was able to sneak up on him and
take him down by surprise
Kelso and agent Sanders someone we
haven't seen since the Pentagon Mission
approached the Panic Room dear Schaefer
and many have been hiding out
Sheffer needs to be returned to his bed
and while on their way many and Kelso
discussed how the black task was able to
take down the network
many acknowledges that he overheard
someone saying that the countermeasures
worked perfectly they know that Schaefer
was the target but as long as they have
the mobile shd server well Limited in
range their skills and cons are working
the next step is to get the White House
defenses back online and find out
whether this shd network blackout is
just local or is in fact a global
shutdown
I'm impressed
credit where credit is due
you and your little team of Misfits
managed to decrypt my calms
you passed the test Manny you really do
have an eye for talent first Schaefer
then Lewis and Wally
imagine my surprise when I discovered
you even managed to recruit Vic I
thought you hated him after what
happened at odia
but here you are welcoming old enemies
into your house and giving them the
literal keys to the castle I haven't
decided if you're a genius with
boundless empathy or a [__] who
actually believes that people can change
people don't change
most of the time
if you think someone has changed it's
because you never really saw them you
never look close enough to see if the
person staring back at you is genuine or
is hiding their true intentions
that's why you're so easy to fool
and why I will always be two steps ahead
of you
I have the Black Tusk the real true sons
and the hunters at my disposal
while your agents have civilians chasing
water bottles
by the way
thank you for sending our agents all the
way to Coney Island to check on
stovepipe
it's too bad you couldn't recruit him
too
but he forgot his place in my
organization and I do not tolerate
disrespect since you may be a [__] I'm
going to make my intentions very clear
this city
this country
this world belongs to us
we will take what is rightfully ours and
there is nothing you can do to stop us
isn't that right Vic
you net
what did you do with Mari and Cindy
don't worry Vic I wouldn't hurt them
they're too valuable to the future of my
operation it's not every day you find a
woman who can build and operate a fish
farm
she really is quite the catch Manny when
you're ready to surrender I would be
more than happy to reunite you to
lovebirds I hear stress can do terrible
things to a pregnancy
especially in older women Manny
if you really do love her
you might want to hurry
oh an agent
I hope to see you soon
this single long condescending comms
pretty much explains everything all
until we've been receiving throughout
this Manhunt has been compromised
this whole time everything we've been
listening to has led us to the setup to
have us removed from the equation so
that the black task can sweep in and
clean up the White House while mummy and
daddy weren't home
it's unlikely that Natalia had anything
to do with the dirty bomb attacks in St
Louis it was just the easiest way of
getting your attention
but it isn't to say that all references
to the recruited novel were just there
disc garrisoned moving out
but I'll get into that a little more
soon
Natalia has also confirmed that she has
Vikram Malik a name that we briefly
heard about earlier on after he betrayed
us at the odia tech building
as well as Mari Singh someone we
suspected would have a larger part to
play after several Khan's messages this
season alone
she not only leads the team at the
central aquarium one of DC's only
sustainable food sources but she is
pregnant with Manny's child
we're gonna have to be careful with any
Direction coming from him after the loss
of his friend and now this is going to
be a mess
but there was one other name that
Natalia mentioned a name I didn't
recognize Cindy
I'm not gonna lie this is the person
Natalia took I hadn't really paid her
much attention up until now based in the
White House Cindy is a drone operator
that has been involved in scouting and
alerting agents to numerous threats in
DC
it was also her drone that worked the
coordinator gtf and shd work on Coney
Island when extracting Vitali tranenko
as well as the Drone that was hacked by
Aaron Keener before he escaped
I'm not overly sure what Natalia is
hoping to gain from Cindy but I'm sure
we'll be finding out soon
on the way into the White House Black
Tusk operatives could be heard saying
the countermeasure is still active and
while many is willing Shafer out of the
Panic Room he says I overheard someone
say the countermeasures worked perfectly
given all of the references to the
recruited novel this season I feel that
it's pretty safe to say that this is
another reference to Thomas parrott's
work
in the novel The countermeasure is the
program Myra used to neutralize the
Rogue Network and Tech at the Kansas
core
this essentially keeps the call from
being destroyed by deactivating the EMP
fail-safes
Natalia has obviously managed to recover
Myra's code and has used it to shut down
the network and attack the White House
so my question how did Natalia get a
hold of this I don't recall anything in
compromised although I'm not going to
read it for the fourth time just to
confirm this
this will probably be one of those
things about Thomas Parrott and Lauren
Stone about over the coming weeks
officially held back on fully talking
about the novels out of respect for the
author and spoilers Etc
but now that we've reached the end of
the first novel in game maybe it's time
I have a run through
[Music]
[Applause]